Dirty bitches. That's when
you saw him. You dirty bitch.
And I need, I need a little, a
little more rhythm to pull it off.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast
today, Tuesday, September 4th,
2012 because how the Blanco is dead.
That's me. That's me. They got
that result of Blanca Lady,
who's that? She's the cocaine cowboys
lady. I still have not seen it.
I was talking about this. We'll
talk about this later. Um,
I got to do a commercial Charlie's
parents podcasts. It's broad,
deep dye on it.com.
That's o and n I t what is on it?
And it's to supplement company.
We make Alpha brain and a bunch of shit
that I talk about on the podcast all the
time. Uh, the one thing I can
tell you is everything that, uh,
we sell it on a.com is all stuff that
I've used, I believe in. I endorse,
I wouldn't get behind
anything that wasn't legit.
And the fascinating thing to me about
Alpha brain is that it's a, you know,
like all the,
all the information from the tropics of
like you're interested in the subject of
nootropics,
which is like,
it's all nutrients that have been shown
to have a positive effect on human
neurochemistry. The idea is that
you, your, your brain produces more,
more juice. You have more ability
to string together sentences.
You have more neurotransmitters.
I don't understand it.
That shit goes away with time,
your receptacles and all that stuff,
it starts to die away.
Everything does. Or going
down, Greg, it's going down.
But what I've, what I've found
is that I benefit greatly from,
I take a lot of vitamins and uh,
I take a lot of really what I believe are
a very effective supplements and I eat
a lot of really good food. You've got
to be healthy because if you don't,
this motherfucker will fail on you.
It will fall apart.
You'll crash into the rocks. Like
you've got to keep it together, bitches.
And that is what Ana is all about.
The company is basically set up.
Everything we sell is stuff that will
improve you with the strength and fitness
equipment,
kettle bells and battle ropes.
There's like the best way you could
ever work out if you want to develop
functional strength, that directly
translates into any athletic endeavor.
Kettle bells and battle
ropes are fantastic.
Battle ropes are these giant fucking
ropes and he flail him through the air and
you do it for like sprints of
30 seconds and oh, it's brutal.
So those and kettle bells,
they will last you for to the end of time.
The battle ropes,
he can't give me any cheaper than you
can get it on [inaudible] dot com and the
kettle bells, there's like as
cheap as you can humanly sell them.
We're sending cannon balls through the
mail. It's not that easy. It's ridiculous.
I mean, that's where senator, I
mean some of them are 90 pounds.
You're sending a 90 pound fucking
cannon ball through the mail.
That shit is expensive as fuck.
It's just like an Alpha brain.
If you want to take the ropes and
make them yourself, go get a bunch of
ropes. It's really expensive.
You'd be amazed. Yeah. Those
really big, heavy, big,
thick, heavy ropes. Those are
expensive as fuck. You know,
it's not easy to target and you got
to go to a, you can get them though.
You can go to nautical stores. I just
don't think they usually sell them in, in,
in the length sizes. Yeah.
It's probably hard to get,
but you can definitely get it. I
mean, we got it. And so just, uh,
it's just a big heavy rope, you know,
if he can make your own, make your own.
If you've got some extra
giant rope playing around,
he could probably do with chains too.
If you want to go fucking crazy rampage
Jackson style or like 17,000 tennis
shoes. Yeah. I mean, the idea is like the,
you're using your whole body in like a
whipping effect in shoelaces. The wind,
like the,
uh,
the amount of a wind it takes to work
out what can do like these 32nd sprints,
20 seconds off, and then 32nd
sprints. That's like, uh,
this protocol of different exercises you
do with the battles are fucking brutal,
man. It's like nothing. It gets you tired.
Like nothing ever do outside
of like wrestling a man.
Not that you do any man wrestling. I
wrestled a rope man once. Rope, man,
that was a fucking workout.
It's alive.
Uh, the father off me off
a water bed when I was two.
Just kidding. You're the only grown man
that I know that still uses. Just kidding.
I know.
What's,
what's the source version of that? Yeah.
Like what's the adult version of that?
Like you don't have to say no,
you're just kidding. I know.
You know the original
one. No, no, no, no. Yeah.
We might not to say that instead of like,
just kidding or not really.
I think it was from, we were
like, you know, ten nine, oh,
I never am more committed.
That's way better.
Black people used to say it in
my town. They'd be like, Nah, no.
All right.
That's my new thing now on at.com o
n n I t go get yourself some fucking
Kettlebell.
Sun Hemp protein powder.
We've got all kinds of groovy shit and
it's all the supplements have a 30 day.
All right, 30 pill rather,
100% money back guarantee.
If you don't feel like it enhances
you and helps you, then you just say,
this stuff sucks and get your money back.
It's that simple.
You don't have to return the product.
Use the code name Brogan and you will
save yourself 10% off you dirty bitches.
All right, Brian, cue the
music. Let's make it official.
Greg Fitzsimmons is here,
Rogan experience,
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day,
and then that happens.
This is what happens.
Every podcast you have these
fucking awesome conversations.
He'd get rolling and then we play that
music and all of a sudden we've got to
start from scratch again and we forget
what we were just talking about that we
were like saving for the podcast.
What were we talking? I said,
we have a very inefficient way of starting
to show and we have never analyzed it
until this moment and
have thought the best
like talk show like tonight show thing
would be as soon as the guests walk in
the stage door backstage,
they should just be getting filmed
and then play pieces of that. Yeah.
You know, cause who gives a shit?
Once they sit down, they tee it up.
It's like I can tell you the
end of George Clooney story.
His mom made cookies and then uh,
she got hit on,
Oh fuck,
fuck about your pre packaged dry ass story
that you've done before. Or they talk,
you know, me talk shows now
you see guys promoting a film.
There's this website that tells you all
the late night shows guests for the next
two weeks and you'll see like Paul
Rudd go fucking daily show tonight.
She'll Laderman cone and you know,
and then start working your way down.
So you're on like a Jimmy, uh,
what's the guy who does a, the late,
late NBC show? No, no, no,
no. It's like he does music.
It was on MTV,
not Jimmy Carson Daly.
Carson.
Carson Daly is still on
television for 10 years.
I like his taste.
I find a lot of weird,
creepy bands and movies from
that guy just because he's,
he's kind of like cutting edge
hipster. Like he, there's a reason why.
Like he was on MTV,
our same generation.
Now he's older so he does give some
cool tastes of music once in a while you
watch it.
When I catch it I always,
I'm interested cause he doesn't pick
little random cards out of the blue that
you maybe you haven't heard of like
music wise, at least we're movie wise.
I don't know. I don't think
he's bad. I I'll take him over.
Leno you no I never said he was bad.
She's fucking hard.
Those things are really hard to do.
It's really hard to do.
Is Talk Show like that. It'd be even
remotely interesting. It's so segmented.
It's like you never really
get a chance to get rolling.
You're just trying to like interject and
say witty things in this really brief
story. It's like you barely get to
know someone like under the, the,
the idea of this,
this breaking it up and for these
long ass commercials and you know,
you talk in between the break and
then when we come back, you know,
and then it just, it's so
fake and Hokey. You removed
yourself and the good guests just say,
you know what I'm going to do?
He's going to introduce me and I'm
going to tell a great fucking story.
Then we're going to go to commercial.
But if you try to fake that,
you're hanging out talking. That's,
that's torture. Special recording music.
An Alienware computer, right? Yeah.
Yes. It's hard to do, man.
It's hard to do that job.
That's a really difficult job.
This is way easier.
It's way easier to do a podcast. Like
there's a, yeah, yeah. Cause the podcast,
you just start talking, you know,
a show like that. Like you have to,
you have to operate within like
this really narrow frame of time.
Like what if this is like
a really intense subject,
something that is a really controversial
to you and the person that you're
talking about it with.
Sometimes it might require
a long time to delicately work
through some weird subject I get.
The guy comes on it and he's talking
about his wife just had an abortion or
something that could do it.
Yeah, it could. Yeah. Yeah.
Well, you know, it's like there's,
there's certain things that when you're,
you're talking about it, you need some
time. You don't want to have to go, uh,
go to pre k and you know like, come
on. Really? Okay, we'll be back.
Cause the host half
fill every second. You get uncomfortable
when the things not going well. So they,
they jump in like some
dysfunctional enabler.
Yeah. The commercial ruins
the conversation. It ruins it,
it fucking kills it.
It's the death of it.
And the idea that you have to do
a commercial at a certain time,
like opie and Anthony have commercials,
but they just talk until they're done.
And then they go, all right, well
you guys want to take a break,
let's take a break.
Placement commercials will write back.
And it's completely organic. Yeah. It's
like you're watching separate shows.
You're like,
you're watching one hour and a half show
where they didn't go to commercial and
then another hour show when they didn't
go to commercial and then they'll go to
commercial.
Well and also you don't get the sense
with opie and Anthony or podcasts that
we're talking the way
to human beings talk.
There's a rhythm and there's a pace and
there's not, there's not high Iq moments.
Every three seconds. Like when you
watch a monologue in an interview,
you had 20 writers mapping every word.
So to me it's off putting,
and I think it is to, a lot of
American sitcoms are the same way.
Human beings don't have conversations
the way they do on sitcoms.
So that's why people started wanting
reality TV. They were like, this shit is,
makes me feel uncomfortable
because it's not real.
Right? Yeah. It's, it's clumsy.
It's like the way the president
talks to the, to the people,
that's the same sort of thing.
It's the same sort of animal.
It's like seeing gene Simmons on his show.
That's just an annoys the fuck out of
me because they stuffed, this is fake.
It's just a really dumb fake, like he
glued dildos to his hand, you know,
like really like this. I have to believe
that you glued a Dildo to your hand.
So unfortunate. Do you know, I guess
it's just trying to keep doing it.
You know Bobby Lee, right? Sure.
Apparently. Uh, apparently he's
talking about this. I'm not,
I'm not outing him about
this when he goes right.
Pretty fine.
How many times have people had to say that
statement in reference to a box store,
which I love. Bobby Lee
loved. I really do love truly.
Well, you know why? Because he's Vaughn,
he's a broken toy and he knows it.
We all know it. So you don't have to. So
that's why I call him the story. He is,
but he goes on the road, he buys
three bottles, a Elmers glue,
and at night he pours it on his hands
and then peels it off. Are you serious?
That's so cool. I heard that and I was
like, I want to fucking do that dude.
You know those markers,
the crayola markers,
you can bite off the end and
then take out the ink out of it.
You put that in a glue overnight and
we'll turn whatever code, color marker.
So you put it on your hand.
You can make it like green hall cans.
So it looks you're peeling off.
Nice tip for Halloween.
Yeah, you should. What are you 12 wrong
was wrong with you,
man.
Like a stone labor action
show hole in his brain, folks.
He took too much ecstasy.
He's like that commercial where they
show the whole do a three d of his head.
God, can we just talk about how it acts to
see, it's just so amazing. There you go.
So I'm going to hone his brain around.
Is this really breaks apart your life
in front of you? Like really accurately?
Like it's really nice. It's if you, if
you talk about, I don't want to just help,
don't do ecstasy, but in my opinion, uh,
like if like mushrooms never really seemed
like they kind of helped me when I'm
like, yeah, that's cool. If was look
like butterflies and stuff where exits,
he actually kind of like,
like almost like you're just start talking
about shit that's bugging you and he
like, like I was really angry the other
day and I just kept on going like,
why am I so angry? Everything
I'm saying is anger and it like,
it really showed me immediately like
what was wrong with me at that point?
It was like a psychiatrist and a pill.
It was weird.
Have you done it much eval done once
or something budget at once? Yeah,
it's don't do it, but
it's amazing. Amazing.
I had a,
I had a positive experience,
like I learned something from it,
but I also realized that
the physical toll yeah.
Is a pretty substantial, yeah.
Your body takes a big flood.
A lot of five HTP and a lot of counter
fucking XSE fix my brain juice and stuff.
So I do it right. Like I've never,
the next day felt like shitty.
Like lot of people wake up the next day
and feel depressed and they, you know,
I've never felt that that was
originally how on it was conceived.
Then roll on and roll off or what hills.
Those are some of the first products and
the idea of being to help reboost your,
your neurotransmitters have to
go on a binge. Yeah. I love them.
Instead of us working towards
people, you know, becoming sober,
we work toward fixes over juice.
Just adopt change.
We just say it's too fun.
It's too fun to not indulge
in my head, man. It's cold.
A liver cleanse or something. What's that?
Can you turn these down, turn you down?
What's going on here?
I feel like I'm at an ACDC concert except
it to you guys talking better? Yeah,
that's great. Thank you. Thank you. Oh,
he's on a different channel or something.
Well y'all ever separate volume chart.
It's crazy. That sounds so deep.
We all have our own separate volume.
Well, who'd you have on last?
They probably turned it up.
I don't remember.
Whoever it was probably had come
in your ears. Whoa. How dare you.
How dare you? Silly boy. Yeah,
that ecstasy on good for
you boy. Yeah. Alright.
Eventually it's going
to rot your head out.
I literally do it once every four months.
Something like that.
I don't do it like every
week or some crazy,
but even once every four months you
PR that's hit and they kind of hard.
Well they say that
it does fuck with your receptors
that you can't get happy.
It's like same thing with opiates.
If you, if you take them too much,
you clog up their receptors and the only
thing that gets through is the drug.
That's why it's so hard to get off of
those fucking pills I can get in is brutal
to get off.
Oof.
I could easily just stock,
never do ecstasy again.
Real friends. Several people that I knew
and grew up with who became pill, pill,
pill people. Yeah, I've seen it happen.
I've seen people lose everything.
See them lose their shit for pills.
Yeah. It's creepy weird rd. One
he went from taking the pills cause it's
basically heroin. It's the same makeup.
And then he couldn't, he didn't have
pills. One time at a club and some happy,
little helpful doorman said,
well why don't you just snort some heroin?
I got some heroin and boom
over. Wow, she's Christ.
I took a right shoulder surgery a couple
summers ago and they gave me Vicodin
way too easily. You know, Revit.
My surgeon gave it to me. Then my,
a general practitioner
gave it to me and uh,
I had a supply gone and I took that shit
for six months. I was taking not a ton,
maybe three,
four a day,
but it started to feel like when I didn't
have one I was not feeling good and
then when I stopped it was some fuck
those toughest two days of my life.
Yeah,
I've heard that the withdrawal is like
almost some people they just can't take
it. It's like a torture and they just quit
and they go back on the pills and say,
you know, I'm, I'm just can't do it. Yeah.
It's terrifying how
easy it is to get them.
It's terrifying how like quick
people are to take painkillers.
Yeah,
I'm good. I mean I like drinking
more than any of this, you know,
like I think that's just something
that I could relax, have a few drinks,
feel good,
but I,
I don't never got into having like
cocaine and it seems like that's just like
once you, you do it once the next day
you wake up and you feel like, shit,
I don't want to do that again.
You know?
Yeah.
I don't get addiction of pills and I
think that opiate thing is a totally
different monkey.
I think once it grabs you,
it just grabs you by the balls and just
intertwines itself with your system.
When you get that monkey on your back,
that's a completely different experience.
I think the opiate one seems to be
more of a intense physical experience.
Yeah, it is. I'll tell you what, I've got
a friend who's been doing it for five,
six, seven years. Very successful.
Screenwriter cannot write without it.
When he take cause writing is a,
it's scary and if you lose all your
fear and you write with abandoned,
that's when you do good writing.
So he started taking them because it
got him out of his writer's block.
But now you start taking it just to get
normal. That's when you're in trouble.
When you're not even getting hot,
you're just trying to crawl back.
They're terrifying and
it's, you know, the people,
and people will call me a hypocrite
because I smoked so much weed.
Hypocrite if a current,
but I can stop and take a week off
and I feel no physical effects.
Like I did recently, went to Hawaii. I
didn't get high for a week. I didn't,
I didn't bother me even a little bit.
It's like there's no withdrawal effects.
There's nothing. I don't think
people understand that. I mean,
some people think that there's some sort
of a psychological withdrawal effect
that some people go through.
And then there's people that just,
their body just completely behaves
differently than the normal person's body.
Yeah. And they have much more of a
proclivity towards addiction. You know,
there's some people apparently that
like any sort of a change in a state of
consciousness,
the brain,
they can look at chemicals in the brain
and see an addictive brain in the way it
behaves.
It's very different.
It's fascinating. And so there are, I
mean, I would never say, I mean, look,
some people die from eating peanuts.
You know, I would never say that mom,
you know, my is my experience in, in
taking anything. It's the same as yours.
So for some people,
pop might just be this impossible
ride into the depths of hell.
I mean, I don't know. I mean, and
then immediately they're hooked on it.
It's not to me, but to someone's with
some really funky, weird genetics.
Someone that can die from cranberries
or some shit. You know what I mean?
Like one of those weird people.
Oh, I mean, addiction in my
family, everybody. I mean, my dad,
my dad died at 51 basically
drinking and smoking and you know,
three and a half packs a day. And
uh, I'm sorry, I hate hearing that.
And aunts and uncles,
everybody's got addiction. So
I quit drinking 21 years ago.
I was 25 years old when I quit drinking.
I remember Greg Pre and post.
Yeah. Yeah. And it was like a, for
me it was like, I know I got to,
so the addiction shifts, you go from one
thing to the next. And for me it was, uh,
drinking,
went to working,
went to sex.
And I really believe that.
I don't know what a sex addict is. We
all want to fuck all the time. You know,
what's,
what's the,
what's the line you cross between
a healthy libido and sex addicts?
You did.
And it was very unhealthy.
Like she did not leave the bed all day
and just wanted to fuck or masturbate all
day.
Well,
some,
some people are just trying to erase
whatever is fucking with their head.
Some they're running horrible
vision from their past, you know,
terrified memories, molestation,
whatever the fuck it is.
Some people just trying to just
rub that out there. Just, you know,
they're just trying to masturbate
to heighten their experience with,
they don't have to think about that
for a brief moment. You know, there's,
there's a lot of people out there that
we're fucked with when they were kids.
I mean, it's a, it's a
terrifying number. It really is.
I kind of get wary to,
when I see somebody who works way too
hard and never lets up on themselves,
I always think you're fucking
hiding from something, you know,
they're not no balance,
real relationship.
It's just people can definitely get
crazy. They can, well, it's, it's,
it's hard because you get so focused on
success and then you're dealing with a
bunch of other ruthless motherfuckers
who are focused on success.
So you have to like up
your game and that's,
that's like the whole drive of modern
man and people get way Douchey or that
way.
It's like you're responding to competing
against each other and you all do shit
out.
Worse and worse do shit
documentary called happy. You can get
it on Netflix and it's uh, it's like a,
you know,
a very academic,
quantifiable look at happiness
and how it transcends cultures.
They started out showing this guy
in India who pulls a fucking wreck,
Shaw and he lives in a tent with
his family and the guys, you know,
it sounds fucking corny.
The Dude's happy, you know,
they followed them and they interviewed
them and they say that 50% of your
happiness is just your wiring.
You, here's your fucking DNA,
here's the juices in your body.
Here's how people,
like they showed a woman who'd
been run over by a truck,
she was a beauty queen and her face is
fucking mangle. It's hard to look at her.
And she returned to her happiness
level within a couple of years.
Same thing with somebody who's depressed.
They can hit lotto within a year.
They've settled back at their baseline.
So that's half.
Then 20% is shit like
status, career, money,
and then 30% is shit.
Like what you do flow,
getting into exercise, getting
into martial arts, getting
into, if you're a writer,
getting lost in something,
that's the other 30% so you have to
strive to control that 30% by not letting
the 20% get any bigger and
giving yourself the room to,
you know, have that balance. And it seems
like exercise, like the number one thing.
Yeah, that's a huge part. You've
got to keep your body alive.
How to keep it moving.
He could keep stressing it.
Got to keep making it keep regenerating.
He keeps sending impulses into it.
Firing your hormonal system,
going to,
you got to force herself to work.
If you don't force your body to work
and wants to just give the fuck up,
you use it or lose it.
But they say the same thing with,
I was saying before how they,
this is where I heard about this in
a documentary about how your, uh,
what are the chemicals
that make you happy again?
Yeah.
Your endorphin receptors start to dry out.
They start to die and the more
you use them, the less they die.
So they say try different activities,
learn a new language, try a new sport,
travel somewhere.
You haven't been
navy.
I don't discount the idea of any like
really big. So I dog experience for,
for helping you. I've, I've, I've learned
a lot about myself doing them, you know,
and he and the regular one that I do
have the isolation tank to start just
getting high and getting that thing, you
know, it's, it's mind blowing enough.
You know, I have, I have some pretty
intense visionary experiences doing,
do you remember them?
Clearly?
Some of them.
Some of them I remember really clearly
the one of talked about it before.
It's so retarded. But uh, it
did, it really did happen.
I was in the jungle and I was walking
through the jungle and there was a bunch
of people,
we were barefoot and they were
talking and I knew their language.
I understood what they were saying.
The language was not English,
it was a different language.
They were talking and I understood
it in their language in my head.
And then I freaked out and then I said,
what the fuck am I?
And then when I freaked out, I spelled
it out to myself like in English,
like what the fuck am I doing?
I am listening to a language and I
understand it in that language but I said
that in English and then I snapped out
of it and woke up and it was the co
repeal this thing because just like when
you have this conversation with me and
I know exactly what you're
saying cause I speak English,
I knew exactly what they were
saying but it was not English,
but I knew what the intent was.
I knew exactly what they were saying and
I understood it in their own language.
It was freaky as fuck cause it's so real.
So you had two selves in a way.
There was the guy watching
the guy speaking the language,
standing, observing. Yes.
Yes, yes. Well that's what woke me
up out of it. I couldn't stay in it.
It was so crazy that I couldn't stay in
it. It was just, it was like what I was,
I wasn't capable of
holding the hallucination.
You ever think about that though?
Because I think that that has a lot to
do with maybe happiness or maybe Saturday
is that we all do have a couple of voices.
You have the guide judging yourself
and then you have your id, you know,
your animal impulses. And uh, you know,
Freud would say it's like your, you know,
your,
your ego and your super ego and that
basically you are observing yourself all
the time and the guy that's
observing you is the fucking asshole.
He's the one that socializing you and
getting you to do what's appropriate,
which you need to a certain degree.
But the balance within that,
I think it's the distance between
the two voices. Uh, you know,
obviously if he completely
became transcendent, maybe,
maybe the Dalai Lama has one voice and
how close can you get those voices?
Hmm. Really close. Yeah.
Well you know, you,
there is the momentum
live and then there's the,
every now and then you are like objective
assessment of the life that you're
living on momentum.
Like sometimes you're just,
life is on momentum for like long
slides and then you need like another
perspective on yourself.
You need to go, what's,
it's going to slow down?
What's going on here buddy?
How are you really thinking
how you really live in?
I think that those reset
situations they can get in life,
whether they're a strong yoga class, you
know, whether it's, uh, you know, right.
The why that I could do it too.
It can be extra. Fuck. Yeah.
We could realize like, Holy
Shit, I'm a fucking loser.
I'm out there driving
drunk. Yeah. For sure.
That could fucking snap you over into
a realistic perspective on what you're,
and the other voice then steps up those,
those little epiphany is going to happen.
And then all of a sudden that,
that guy that was in the flow, it's
like, dude, get in the back seat.
I got the wheel for a little while. You're
going to get it back on the road here.
You know? And it's like,
uh, you know, for me,
having a wife and kids, uh, and not
drinking, I don't have much escape.
So I really do struggle with that.
Like the guy that's telling me to do
the right thing and I realized I drive a
fucking Prius. I have college
savings accounts for my kids.
I fucking exercise.
Like it's great stuff,
but there's a part of me that feels
like that animal inside, you know,
and I'm not going to fuck around,
you know, I'm not going to drink. Uh,
so I try to find other ways and part,
part of it is just being a clown when
I'm out with my wife, I fuck around,
but everybody parking
attendant, waiter, I just,
to me it's like being out with her and
having fun as a fucking greatest and
making her embarrassed and she protest,
but she loves it and that's a
relationship. Know really funny.
That sounds like fun. That's
what I was looking for him. Yeah.
I put a Napkin on my head at a restaurant
last week and she actually got mad at
me because I wouldn't take it off.
It was like a really nice restaurant.
I want to see this such a,
it's Simmons sense of humor moment.
You just love,
just love being able to do that though.
Do it. And realize that you are
so different from me. That's what,
that's what you're saying.
Cause she grew up,
she grew up in New York City in a fucking
not a great neighborhood and she's
sophisticated chick. You know, she
got her masters in social work and,
and you know,
but she's not wild at all.
She's very dressed down.
But she accepts me because she's been,
she grew up around insanity. Right, right,
right. So it's a perfect combination.
And she read, she reigns me in
peacefully. She's not a nagging wife,
she's not a ballbuster,
but she is almost that other voice
that gently I just watch her and she
peacefully brings me back into my
kids. You know, sometimes, you know,
sometimes you,
you go away and you come back and you
see your kid and it's like you're not
connected and you gotta you
gotta work your way back in.
And she's like, my guide,
she brings me back into it.
That's awesome man. Yeah. If
you can find someone, you,
you just Joe with them and
you enhance each other.
That's what relationships are all about.
The, I mean that's what we all hope for,
but it's the crazy thing is how rare that
is. What it's worth too. I don't think.
Sure. Not a perfect soulmate.
It's you know, but I mean,
how many people do you know that are
truly happy in their relationship?
Oops. What is the percentage, you know,
how many people do you
know that are struggling?
How many people you know
that fight a rally? Half.
Probably the married couples I
know really like have a like to the
point where they say it out loud.
It's a thing.
Yeah.
Yeah. I would say that you're,
yeah, I would agree with you.
I think the people that I come
in contact with, it's about half,
half of them seem like nice couple,
look at that.
They seem friendly and seemed like they
enjoyed each other's company and then
half of them snipe at
each other and you know,
and they do it right in front
of you. Oh man, that's so rude.
You know what I'm doing. You know
what I'm doing. Just stop it. Stop it.
Now do you see what he does? You see
it right? This is what I deal with.
Oh,
those relationships are ruthless to
watch man. Cause that's out in public.
You can imagine what it's like
behind closed doors. You know.
Did you see that video of a basketball
player who was a first round draft pick?
Did you see that Brian,
the dude beat his girlfriend up
and did it on camera. Oh yeah. Yes.
Prep his daughter.
Like was it in front of his daughters?
Were a little girl there. Are you talking
about like he reached over the fence?
No, no, no, no. This was um, it was,
it looked like it was like some sort
of a hotel or a or a apartment lobby or
something like that somewhere where they
had a security camera wherever it was.
He's this big fucking dude,
big super athlete basketball player.
And he like kicks her to the ground
and smacks her in the head and you're
watching us. It's terrifying.
She's really little man.
She's not a big person and he is giant
and apparently he just beat her ass and
they sentenced him to a
bunch of different shit. Man.
They sentenced him to like all told,
I think he has to go to jail for like
three years. And uh, yeah. And he,
he just, when he probably dropped
the fucking $20 million contract,
you should see the video to the video
is crazy. He collapses in the courtroom,
collapses and it was like,
oh no, no, no, no, no.
Fell down. Collabed I mean it was,
it was really fucking intense.
It's terrifying.
I mean,
he realized that he was going to
go to jail for three fucking years.
You know what sucks about that is that
ain't gonna change the dude and that
ain't going to change any other
domestic abuser putting people in jail.
It's like, why isn't
there more like, you know,
especially in the inner city where you
see people with less father figures and
you see more violence to,
to really make it a part of schools
that you learn how to respect women,
how to respect, you
know, the opposite sex.
Because it is something that
is cyclical and it is cultural.
You see a higher instance of domestic
abuse with poor people and you know that
should jail doesn't change that shit.
It just causes more anger.
Yeah. It, it, it's not like it's a great
place where they're going to, you know,
sit around and do Iowasca and find
their spirits of realize where they went
wrong and the path to enlightenment
surrounded by dudes. Yeah. It's a mess.
The whole idea is a mess.
And then you get into the
fact that there's private
prisons in this country and
that that's one of the most mind boggling
facts about American culture and just
makes you wonder like,
what is,
what is the intention of the people
running this fucking place where they've
allowed so they got vacancies,
they're losing money.
You gotta fucking get some
reservation people out there.
That's what the cop side, their
reservation is for the prisons. Yeah.
It's almost like that, huh?
Yeah. It's funny that like the,
the police officer's unions will
actually, uh, lobby and vote.
They like try to make sure that certain
drugs aren't made legal and like they
have a, Oh shit. Yeah,
sure. It makes sense. Yeah.
Police officers in unions or not
police officer's unit, but um, uh,
what would they call them? What did they
call the people that worked at jails,
corrections officers,
corrections officers.
They will actually like use their money
and influence to try to make sure the
drugs stay illegal. Speaking
of which, number one, domestic
abusers in the country,
corrections officers. Really, Jesus
Christ, super high rate of alcoholism.
Or I read this book about singers. It's
a terrible job. It's terrible for them,
man. I mean, I don't have anything
against corrections officers. I,
it's a terrible place to be,
to be just completely surrounded by
people who are locked in a cage and you're
not,
and you walk amongst them all the time
and they can just take a fucking free run
at you at any moment. You live your life
and constant stress. Yeah. Yeah. I don't,
I don't envy them by any
stretch of the imagination.
I think that if you're going
to really take, being, uh,
putting someone in a jail
and reform seriously,
you're going to have to come up with a
way better method than what they're doing.
This is ridiculous because this is
a reforming anybody, there was a,
I read this book about Sing Sing.
This journalists went undercover as a
prison guard for two years and he came out
of it.
He divorced his wife,
he was an alcoholic and he was living
in a fucking one bedroom shack.
His whole life fell apart and he said
that the, the alcoholism on the inside,
he said, it's just end.
It becomes consuming.
It becomes a challenge that you
take with you when you leave work.
It's not you go to your job,
you finish and then you go have your life.
It becomes these motherfuckers and I'm
going to do this and it eats you up.
You become part of it. Yeah.
Human beings are weird as fuck.
Trying to figure out how our behavior
lends us astray or leads us astray rather
and how we can try to get it back on
track if it's at all even possible like as
a, as a group of us. It's like
when you look at the, the,
the just the massive amount of crazy
human momentum type behavior where we're
just on our momentum.
Like,
here's the thing in New York where they
had to recently pass something that
makes rabbis have to get consent
first before they suck your kids.
Dick suck. Yes. Do you know
when you circumcise a child,
the rabbi that traditionally will suck
upon the boy's penis to stop the bleeding
now? Yes, yes, yes. This is all Jewish.
I don't know what sect of Judaism. I don't
really care what they call themselves.
Whatever. Silly people do
this. It's real. It's they've,
they've had babies die in very recent
times because the baby will get herpes
from the mouth of the, the whatever.
I think they called them. Loyal. Yeah.
Sense of tradition.
There's a guy that's like,
there's this nutty fucking video of this
guy defending it and he explains it in,
in the, the word, the Hebrew word,
which means to suck like that.
It's strictly says if that's how
you're supposed to deal with that.
So that's what they're doing. So,
and you're just discounting my,
my thought is that you're just discounting
that this fucking baby's not going to
remember this experience.
You know?
How do we not know that that's some
nightmare in the back of his mind,
like constantly fucking with them.
They did.
Cutting the Dick is where it starts
cutting a deck and then sucking it. It's,
it's, you know, they say tannic shit.
It's, it's tribal. It's fucking,
and it all goes back to shit.
It's like,
you know that the American
Medical Association no longer
recommend circumcisions
in third world countries they do
to prevent aids and uh, other, uh,
that's never got that. How is getting
your dick cut going to prevail?
It used to be because the,
the fold around the crowd would that good.
You're going to get aids that way.
Really? Really? It's so ridiculous.
I think it gets infected more because
there's shit that gets in there like wash
your Dick. You don't get it.
That's my point. We got running.
People can't even wash the, Oh, so
because we don't have running water.
They're getting aids through. They're
there for skins, which is true. Therefore,
skin makes aids. Well, anything
that folds back around the gland,
like a vagina basically collects way
more diseases than a penis. You know,
like men don't catch aids almost ever
so straight up sex with a woman who has
aids. But if you've got a vagina, you've
got a really good chance of getting aids.
If you have sex with somebody,
if you have any kind of tear in your
vaginal wall or ceilings or floors or
shades or blinds, your lips, oo, slats.
Uh,
do you know that there's a doctor who
doesn't believe that it's terrifying when
someone,
when you're too stupid to know who's dumb
because there's this guy who's a,
uh,
his name is Dr Peter Duesberg and I've
read all his stuff and I know that he's a
professor of biology. I believe the
University of California Berkeley.
It's like a legit guy.
And his whole idea is that
HIV is not what causes AIDS.
Oh yeah.
I heard about the president of South
Africa said the same fact titty really the
biggest aids country.
And the other way I met HIV before and I
was talking about transmitting diseases.
Nowadays,
I am way too stupid to understand who's
right and who's wrong then because
obviously there's a bunch of geneticists
and a bunch of disease specialist who
completely disagree with him and
they think that HIV does cause aids.
I wish I was smart enough to know what
the fuck who's where. It's ridiculous.
Well it's all shit happening
at a molecular level. It's
all, it's all guesses.
It's,
but it's percentages and if you say that
when we see these symptoms of a immune
deficiencies happening and people there
have lesions in her losing weight,
then we often find that before
that they, you know, uh, that,
that the immune leads to the lesions
and all of the outbreak of aid.
So why not play those odds since we'll
never know the actual truth if there even
is one.
Do you think that's what they're doing?
I what Duisburg is saying is that there,
it's linked to partying. What he's
saying is that it's a dude's do like, um,
math and go crazy poppers,
poppers and Emile nitrates.
Apparently those poppers are
unbelievably bad for you. Like,
like instant brain damage and that doing
that partying on a regular basis like
that just wrecks your immune system.
Well that's,
I mean it's why third world countries
get aids more is because when you're
malnourished and your system is worn down,
you Terry easier,
your tissues break open and your immune
system can't fight back as much. So it's,
you know, it's, it's about, you know,
wealthy countries get it less because
they're fucking, they're in better shape.
So you, what you think is at HIV
is something that can be avoided.
I think it,
it,
I think the likelihood of getting it as
increased when your system is worn down
and you're malnourished and uh,
you know,
you don't have enough fluids in you then
you tear and that's where the, uh, you,
you have more cuts around
you because your, your skin,
everything is just not as elastic
frog.
And that's all coming from sex.
That it's just completely
sexually transmitted. Yeah.
You put a penis and a vagina and you rub
it back and forth and something tears
and then the semen gets
in there. Boom. HIV.
Remember when you were a kid, you thought
everybody would be dead of AIDS by now.
I now we were convinced we
caught the wave. We got fucked.
Who got scared? Remember you get,
do you ever remember what uh,
happened the first time we took an
aids test? Yes. Did you panic? Yeah,
I fuck and panic because it's like a
24 hour wait a fucking bannock man.
I fucking had panicked or thought about
some weird drunk nights on the road as a
20 year old, 21 year old.
Come on man. I had to,
I caught gonorrhea once. I
crossed the chlamydia green.
When you pa like his ass,
it hurts.
It hurts worse than any and you're
fighting your need to urinate all bladder.
But every ounce to comes out you are
ready to fall on the floor screaming.
Wow. Yeah, it's nice.
And then one shot in the ass did dawn
is the syphilis outbreak in porn.
Really?
Some dude got syphilis and then
like didn't show his full medicals,
didn't show,
he fakes the shot.
He took a shot and he thought he
was clean 10 days. That's his story.
And apparently 11 days.
He didn't even,
we waited one day and then the next day
he did a movie and gave people syphilis
cause it's dominoes. She then have
sex before. I mean he didn't even,
I mean you didn't even get another check.
It didn't even get another blood test
to see if it's still in the system.
He didn't even, he just said I got to
work. Well because you don't have to it.
My friend is the head of the uh,
the um,
a venereal disease department of
the Health Service for California.
His whole thing is trying to get,
I mean he knows as much about porn is
I do because that's his whole thing is
like, you know, when they
started using condoms,
that was him and he said that the testing,
once a month you get tested,
which means that gestation period
for HIV is like 20 days or whatever.
Right.
So you're never really catching it.
And that there's one agency that does
the testing for all the porn movies and
it's not even a medical office. It's
not, it's not a doctor. The clinic. Yeah.
But they closed all these
play places down there.
They're all forced to go to one place
now where it used to be really convenient
that like you should be able to
go to any doctor, get a test,
get all the tasks because it's all the
blood sent to the same places as these
labs, but they're not
letting them do that anymore.
So now they're all forced to go
to this one sketchy plays and,
and so there's all these
creepy people at hangout. They,
you're trying to fuck with them and
stuff like that. And it's, yeah,
and it's also they have to pay for it.
The actors pay for the test themselves.
What fucking job that you go to that
right? I mean, first of all, it's a law.
You have to give tests it to work.
If it's a law,
why the fuck are they paying for it?
Yeah. That is a business that didn't
get a bailout, that business crumbled.
I mean there's God's still making money.
There's like the very
clever computer guys.
But you think about like the business
of pornography and how many people watch
pornography.
And then the fact that all of a sudden
no one was paying for it anymore,
like all of a sudden it all just went
away and it's gotten bigger and porn is
everywhere. Yeah, it's everywhere in the
Mitt. Romney gets an off. What do you say?
Number one profit tier from pornography?
Yes. Who It is? Mitt Romney?
Nope. Close. It's another Mormon.
Really? Oh, the Marriott family.
They own more hotel chains that sell
porn and that's the only place people are
paying for anyway. They're the number
one profit or from pornography.
Squeaky clean Mormon people do
pay for it still. Allegedly.
I should say that so I don't get that.
They're squeaky clean. No, no. They fit.
They're the number one. I think they may
well if they're not number one there,
they made a fuck load of, I would
say motel six with me. Number one.
I think they own it.
I think Marriott owns a lot of this
chain auger still sturdy pornographers to
Marriott's. Isn't that crazy?
When was she found out?
They made like millions a year from
pornography as businessmen in the road
weeping at the end of the bed.
Lisa,
the expense account, I don't have
to, that's why they do it so much.
It's all in the expensive. They don't
question you for those $40 movies.
Hey don't mark them anymore.
They don't mark anything.
They don't give you a title on
the bill. Just moving horse. Yeah.
They can't give you a title in the bill
that they had to know a long time ago.
That was a must. When you block porn,
cause I'm assuming you don't anymore.
What was your thing? What section? Real
and shopping. I didn't ever have a thing.
Never really got like too specific.
It's uh,
you know the thing about porn
is this different, you know,
you want to see different
people, you know, you know,
even if one girl is really pretty,
you get bored.
I got, I started off girl girl only.
Like I didn't even want any grades.
Picture Brian's like,
let me just pretend that we're all on a
slumber party and I'm going to be your
best B f f ever.
Well, it's just something I didn't
see every day. Like I have had sex,
but like I never saw two girls together.
Right. Shit was like aliens to me. Yeah.
It's,
it's strange.
Yeah.
Um, but they look happy. Usually.
I just like to see a dream crushed
and Mike Clip, I need a dream crusher.
A casting couch or oh, those are
the best. Those are hilarious.
Or the,
the was it was it bang bus that used to
have you guys pull over and people would
just fuck get it in the car.
We got a porno star. Holy Shit.
Now my favorite,
now it's fucking machine.
Wasn't that kid the kid that was in
some, what was it? What movie was that?
Okay.
The kid that had done a porn when he
was young, he did like a bang brothers.
Oh, Jonathan. Yes. Yeah.
From project tax. Yeah. Yeah.
What was his story again? Uh, he just,
he did a, uh, I think it was a bang bus.
How old was he? I think he'd be just
turned 18 or something like that.
He's a John. Johnathan came and think
it was written it last name right now,
but he was in that movie project
acts and he's like a big Chubby,
nerdy kid with glasses and he
was in a movie where he fucked,
I think it was his first time too,
like four girls in a bus.
And He, the funny part was though
is that it really for girls,
I think it was and the funny thing
was is that he had like a huge hog.
So it's just like, it was like so weird
that like I actually knew him before,
like, like we had them on,
I had him on a few podcasts,
like I didn't know about it and such.
I think knowing a guy and then finding
out you this in porn and then seeing is
he his hog that happened with me with
a, you know, seven racks from MTV.
He was like one of the original VJ then.
Yeah, it doesn't, he has another name now.
He has a band now. Yeah, exactly. And
He's good. He's fucking good. Yeah. Good.
But on my podcast, is
that what, what song?
the 80s is that what it is?
And I can't remember about the eighties
fuck no, I'm going to go crazy.
We'll drop into the podcast
later. But um, yeah, but he did
some kind of, he just masturbating.
But I think it was a big hit with the,
with the men gentlemen
came out like after he was famous.
No,
I'm going crazy trying to remember
this fucking song. You so crazy.
Shut the fuck up.
What's wrong with you today?
You've got to stop doing ecstasy
so much. Breaking your brain, man.
Holy Brain. What's the
fuck machine? Cheesy
brain fog machine is a, it's the called
the fucking machines.com I think it is.
And it's actually robots that Oh
fuck. Really high powered. Like,
like you know like Oh cool.
Shoot in and out of them like 80 miles
per hour and they can't control it.
Like they're tied down. So like there's
somebody sitting there going, yeah,
I'm going to fuck you hard. And
like, it's really crazy. Like Dana,
dear mom did it and it seems like
break your pussy. Yeah, that's a good
way to get your pussy all broken.
So machine robot metal deck,
but just fucking stabbing,
you know. Well what if, what if it goes a
little too hard? I know. Let's run with it
or where you hold the other end. Is it
that much of a Chore Machine? Fuck you.
You gotta be real careful
about that kind of shit. Shit.
And what's crazy is that that people
on those web cam sites are now doing it
because they have like these, I guess
you can easily buy him now for your home.
Like,
like a portable one that's just like,
or they may come from
like a hardware store,
but like there's this one girl that
she's just so it's like getting up,
like the Dodo is like,
I don't know,
12 inches maybe like a huge dildo.
And she was giving a blowjob to it,
put it on full blast or you can just
see it like her, her throat get bigger,
like a snake eating a watermelon and it,
and it's,
it was like you're gonna hurt yourself.
You're going to break something,
you're going to choke and or you're
going to crack your neck open. So crazy.
And what's weird is that
what is like the, with the
algorithm in your brain that wants,
like when you talk about different,
like I used to love Asian chicks,
got another feet. I was never like, I'd
let me suck your feet and your call,
but I appreciate a nice pair of feet,
especially on an Asian woman.
Let's just put that out there.
So then,
then I move on to the cast and catch
and I start to wonder on a deeper level,
what is it about my personality or my
brainwaves that attracts me to a specific
thing.
And then what is it that has so broken
down the social order that people respond
to machines. Fucking, it's
like the flesh, the softness,
the humanity has been stripped away and
all that's left is the violent part of
fucking
do. Have you heard of this new,
um, this discovery at Harvard,
they've created a cyborg flesh of course
at Harvard because nobody can get later,
right? Yeah, exactly. I mean,
but along those lines like this is
like literally step one until you,
you create a robot that's going
to fuck you up. Amit. Robot.
This is nuts, man. Fuck the flying
jet. This is pretty intense shit.
It's to create the Cyborg flesh.
You start with a three dimensional
scaffold that encourages
cells to grow around them. These
scaffolds are generally made of Collagen,
which makes up the connective
tissue and almost every animal.
The Harvard engineer's basically took
normal collagen and wove nano wires and
transistors into the matrix to
create a nano electric scaffold.
The neurons,
heart cells,
muscles and blood vessels
within grown as normal,
creating cyborg tissue with
a built in sensor network.
Is this the plot of a porn movie or
this is reality. This is reality, man.
This is crazy shit.
This is like Cyborg flesh.
Like they're figuring out a way to
replace your skin with robot skin.
I'm going to see you in 20 years from
now and you're going to be a 24 year old,
handsome man,
Asian.
They're going to take your whole body
and slowly replace your skin with some
fucking robots. Can. I'm going to
have to get used to young Greg.
It's going to be weird. What about
the hair? Talk to me about the air.
Get your fuck.
Even if I could grow my hair,
I'd go back to shaving it and it was
freeing feeling. Just rub it through.
But it will stop you from getting
a certain type of exam. Hard life.
They're there. They've created
and court officials. No, no, no.
I'm saying this is step one to be a
robot. You know, that is your sex slave.
Well, that's why, you know, it's
all male scientists and the women,
they're like Israel trying to fucking
defunk uh, Iran's nuclear program.
They're coming in at night
exposing all this tests. Totally,
totally, totally throwing,
fucking painted them and shit.
You're never going to get their fake pussy
fucking white laboratory
on fire while they sleep.
Yet he finally think they've got,
when she comes out and they
design it like a garbage,
it's spells of the pussy just
fucking devours that little Dick,
that little Harvard Dick.
You're so funny though. Sexual Boston
to you say that little Harvard tick.
Okay.
You're getting, you're fucking, you're at,
you're at your graduation with the
count on trying to hide the stump.
This, this, this thing
is really complicated.
I don't think I even
understood what I just said,
but what would it seems
to me is that this is,
I mean they're going to be,
they can create flesh.
They've already figured out
how to do that. They can,
they figured out a way to create meat
in like essentially like a test tube
environment they've had,
you know,
so it's just a matter of time before
and the meat is replicated DNA.
Is it? Is it green? Understand it. I'm
too stupid to answer that question.
I guess the big,
the big turn is getting it to actually
reproduce itself DNA like it does in
humans.
Exactly.
But it seems to me that if they
could replicate one aspect of it,
if they could figure out how to meat,
it's just a matter of time.
It's like we went from the model t
Ford to the, you know, 2013 corvette.
It's like it gets better. It gets
better, it gets better, it gets better.
It's when they're doing this now,
this is what they're doing now.
This is going to expand into
something else incredibly freaky.
This is going to be incredibly,
incredibly freaky. This is cyborg tissue.
I mean this is, you can
make a fucking cylon. Okay.
You could make a Cyborg like this is
step one. When they look back in history,
when life is like Battlestar Galactica
fucking for real and we really are
fighting off these intelligent
robots that we created.
This will be the day where people
look at this and go, wait, what did,
what did they do? What did they make?
What did they started with this?
And then goes from this to what?
And by the time they tell you about this,
how far are they along on this? There'll
be the ones telling you about it. Yeah.
Clones. Clones will be
telling you about cloning. We,
well we figured out how to clone this
just cause it guy is clone who's telling
you about it.
Yeah. And, and the amazing
thing is that you look at,
like I went to the Santa Monica promenade
the other day and they come out of the
five story parking garage with a line
of cars at two different stations.
No human being like you're literally
collecting between five and $10 every 15
seconds all day and night.
You can't pay 12 bucks an hour to
some fucking guy to have a job.
And that's what's happened is that they
talk about unemployment is his dad.
You know, the unemployment
rate is high. Well,
it's not just high because
the economy's not doing good.
It's they're slicing jobs with
machines everywhere. Just to stay at.
Even with the job rate,
you would have to be creating x number
of jobs every month and with these
cyborgs, what the fuck? Who's,
who's going to have a job anymore?
Yeah. Who's going to have any
sort of a manual labor job?
I welcome the side work friends.
I think I rather enjoy paying a machine
and talking to the Hershey garage.
The idea, I think it's faster too.
So it's, it's more convenient.
It's faster. So there's a crop. We are
so crazy because here's the problem.
They are going to be intelligent.
If they're going to be intelligence,
they're going to be able to be sentience,
which means they're going
to have their own will.
They can do whatever
they would like to do.
The first thing they're going to
do is make a better one of them.
They're going to realize what we did
wrong. What was stupid about this?
This is shitty. You thought
about this like a person would,
let's Redo this better. And they'll
do that almost instantaneously.
That's the big question in all of this,
since the 1950s when they started talking
about robots and stuff is can there be
a [inaudible],
can there be that transition
from something that's been
programmed to something
that can control itself?
You know, it'd be really horrifying
if there never was a cent yet moment,
but it acted as if there was one and it
just ran around like this meat puppet
program.
Just fucking gun and holes and people.
Yeah cause it didn't know
what it was supposed to do.
Yeah. You can just throw him in a toilet,
pour some water on him, you know, stop.
You know like that's like a cell phone.
Eight is electronics and my
think twice probably have that covered.
That whole get wet part. It'll still,
they already know how to
do that with cell phones.
You know there's like some product
they dip it. No Shit. Yeah,
they dip your cell phone in this product
and you can like literally drop in the
ocean, pull it out, dry it off
and make this thing cell phone.
You can bring it in and they do this.
Yeah. You send them the cell phone,
they take it and soak it in some kind
of crazy polymer that doesn't have,
I don't know the word polymer.
I shouldn't be allowed to say it cause I
don't even know what the fuck a polymer
is. Whatever. Plastic Shit.
How about that? Some awesome,
super cool plastic shit.
[inaudible] water from getting through
to the electronics and somehow or another
I don't understand it.
That's weird. Yeah, but the,
there's demonstrations of it online.
I can't remember the name of it,
but if you're so curious you will
Google it. You just hit your cock in it.
Never wear a condom. Yeah. I don't
think you'd feel pee as much.
Y'all black saying shit like every time
you're in the shower with your girl you
got a boat or she's like, why is
it so? I see this is so weird.
It's like you never just beating up on it
like the hood of a fucking Chevy,
like your deck on fire
and stick it in the cake,
isn't it?
Dan is one of the nicest qualities
about those old American muscle cars was
those big long,
giant hoods.
When you wax the car and then it rained
and the water beat it up on that thing
and you just kind of swipe the
water off those fucking cars, man,
those were works of
art. I get to show you this Mustang
I saw today. I was over in Burbank
before Burbank. Nupur everywhere.
Wherever CBS Radford is. That's Burbank,
isn't it? Parking garage, studio city.
And uh, there was this, don't be a hater.
Don't be starting gang
violence. Check this out. Feel
some kind of special cat. It
said like California. What is it?
California additional what?
What he's showing me
look like a 68 Mustang.
But it had these, uh, maybe you'll
recognize it. I'd never seen him.
It's hilarious to me how a guy like you,
it doesn't have some fucking
crazy car like this. It's Todd.
You're already convinced me head
writer job on it. What's that?
I said this is an old one
that looks like a 67 maybe.
I don't know that it's got
scopes on the side by the doors.
The lines of those cars were just so
beautiful and it was a three 50 like
special edition. It sat on the side.
But no, I'm up for a head writer job.
It's why I was just over there.
And if I get it,
I'm pulling the trigger cause I'll be
commuting to fucking CBS Radford from
Venice. I think I'm gonna
get the challenger to get by.
It's a lot of gas, gas,
but feel like a fucking
man when you get in there.
The rumble of the engine.
I rented a Mustang in Ohio, my wife
in the back and not like, yeah,
he rented a Mustang and didn't like
2012 convertible Mustang. It was just,
you were just telling me about.
I have one, I love it. Yeah.
But here's a different style.
I think.
Well I have the, the, it's a different,
what's different experiences?
The GT 500 it's 550 horsepower.
So aluminum block engine and the Ford
gt engine put into this wobbly as
convertible body. It's
beautiful. It's so much fun.
It's the most American Dick
hard car I've ever driven. Okay.
I wouldn't want to drink black.
I wouldn't want to drive it every day,
but when I drive it, it's
fun. It's fuck, it's just,
I don't even think about playing anything
except seventies rock in that car
because it's just got that as a rumble.
The VI Lenon scanned it all the way.
I got it on a big Leonard Skinner kick
when I bought this car cause I'm like,
this is the kind of music
you need to be listening to.
Simple man is perhaps the most moving
rock song father telling his son
how to be a man's fucking great on the
battle of the ballot of Curtis Lowe.
Yeah. Yeah. They had, they had some
classic shit, so fucking underrated.
But there's something about dudes that
guys can, for whatever stupid reason,
like really viscerally connect with the
sound of an engine of a car and you know
that kind of like,
you know,
1970s in 19 late 1960s classic rock,
they ball together into one really like
guy centric experience and I dunno what
the fuck it is.
It's really weird.
Like I've tried to assess my love
for the rumble of an engine before,
like why it's so retarded with me.
Like I get it like a shriek,
like a little child when I hear a good
engine whale. Like I just fucking love it.
It just sounds awesome, but
it's stupid. It's so stupid.
Like wouldn't it be better
if it was completely silent?
Like that's what I don't like about
the Prius that it's totally side.
But wouldn't that be awesome?
You know,
it was for one thing and this fucking
stupid life to not just make a shit load
of noise everywhere it goes.
Wouldn't that be awesome?
You know what, give me a Prius
that has a fake sound when I the,
it just plays on the inside of the car.
Well do you know the, they
have a BMW that does that. It,
the BMW m five has the sound of the
engine transmitted through the speakers.
It's really kind of a
cheesy move but it's,
and it's an automatic double clutch.
It's an automatic,
but the best way to drive
it is to use the paddles.
You know like when they like tracking down
the track. It's a, it's an amazing car.
I mean it's not,
there's nothing bad about the car,
it's just the decision to like make
the sound come through the stereo.
It seems like cheating.
Like it sounds like what it sounds
like they had to make it a, a,
a turbo because um,
there's all these new crazy gas efficiency
laws that are coming out and it's
really hard to make a the same
like gas guzzler type engines.
By the time I think it's 2016
I believe it is, every car is going
to have to be above 35 miles account.
That's going to be the industry standard.
So like all these cars,
like these mustangs and shit,
you won't be able to buy them
just in a few years from now.
You can't get anything retarded in
a few years. Yeah. Because like it,
and by the way, the, the, the Shelby,
the Gt 500, somehow or another,
it doesn't even get a gas
guzzler tax, you know, I don't,
I don't know how that is huge.
It's a huge VA,
but they figured out something,
make it really efficient. Yeah.
You were saying that,
what was the,
the car you can bring on a track
that got better mileage than a Prius,
uh, be a BMW m three. Yeah. When you
bring a Prius on to attract top gear,
did this,
they,
they took a Prius and they made it go
full blast around a race track and all the
BMW had to do was keep up with it and
the BMW kept up with it easily and got
better gas mileage than the Prius did.
Hmm.
Because the Prius was fighting for its
fucking life or as the BMW was just like
sprinting.
Well. Yeah, but I think the Prius
is designed to save you money.
Stop and go through town.
It's not not, not for highway.
Yeah. That's the whole point of the brakes
generating extra power, right? Yeah.
The breaks help
and it's got it down to,
mine's got to down shift thing now,
so you actually collect even more it,
it'll decelerate the way
if you downshifted wood and
collect that energy when
you're going to pull the trigger.
As soon as I get this job,
I'm going to find out in the next week.
Okay.
Women will never understand
these conversations,
but we'll never understand
fucking handbags.
Do you ever get a handbag
conversation with Mrs Fitzsimmons?
Not like that at all.
Oh God.
We just went to a big wedding and
she borrowed handbags. Jewelry.
I felt like such a dude
dress. I'm like, book go shit.
She shopped for two fucking
weeks and didn't find anything.
I go into a store and it's very simple.
I need a shirt.
I'm going to this store. I'm walking
out with his shirt. That's all it takes.
Pants, this store walk, Christmas
shopping, got to buy some for the wife,
this store coming out with something.
She spent two weeks going in
and out and did not find any.
That boggles my fucking mind.
She had the best affairs ever.
No one has got no class. It's keeps
on leaving. I know all these guys.
Warmth,
warmth,
the way your wife shooting.
She found a friend that had addressed
though that. Yup. That's weird.
That's hilarious. So what does your wife
usually wear? Like lumberjack shit. Like,
yeah,
she's into flannel Timberland's
she's got a hay hay in her hair now.
She does.
She works like she's got big tits so
she'll wear 34 days and tight jeans.
Not Tight, tight, but you know, she's got
a good fucking body man. I swear to God.
I had sex with her the other day and
I was just like, fuck God damn it.
Your body's nice. You know, I check
her out all the times. And uh,
she, she initiated, it was fucking
night milky. She initiated,
he's given us full details.
I mean in, you know,
in the living room and walked
in. Music wanted it. Okay.
And the music player now what was on TV?
I was like something like
seeing how it was on my laptop,
on the chair in the living
room and she fucking lap dance.
We would know music and then we
threw down on the couch and uh,
and then she just walked away, kept
on doing her shit. It's Tuck it.
Would it be funny if Greg and his wife
didn't really have sex at all anymore but
he liked,
could written all these stories but it
gets a crossed up and he doesn't realize
he told us this one already,
but it was a little different
before it was on the couch.
He said the same thing
about her walking away.
You imagine catching
someone in a crazy lie,
the best marriage ever and just find
out, oh death. That was the saddest.
I saw a little bit of this
movie with Kevin. Kevin James.
It's a fucking good actor.
Good Act. I mean, I, my kids
watch when all these movies,
and not only does he do physical comedy,
but his face can do so much shit.
Even in drama. He's a powerful dude.
His, um, here comes the boom moving,
here comes the boom, movie's coming out
in October. And that's a movie where he,
uh, plays a MMA fighter. He plays
a guy, was a college wrestler.
He's fucking great in it, man. He can,
he can act and he can take those silly
high concept movies like that and
actually grounded enough to make it
funny. But this movie, anyway, he's,
he's about to,
uh,
his friends get to propose and he's
telling me how great marriages,
he's trying to drag them anyway.
And then the guy sees his wife cheating,
calls are on it. And she
goes, well, what do you,
what do you know about our marriage?
He goes and gets a fucking hand
job from a Thai girl every Friday,
and it all falls apart. You know?
And this guy wants to get married,
but he realizes that every married
person is spinning another fucking story
about their marriage. And to me
it's like you either stay married,
like getting divorced.
You should never do
until you need a divorce,
then you should get a fucking divorce.
But to live a lie in a marriage,
why not kill? You're not alive
if you're doing that. Yeah.
Some people just can't change.
They have a real hard time just
moving on to the next thing.
We'd have a really hard time
just changing. It's very
difficult for some people.
That's one of the things in this happy
movie, it talks about how the pain,
the thing that you think is gonna
be losing your job, going, bro,
even getting kicked out of your house,
it's not as bad as you
think it's going to be.
And the fear of it happening
controls so much of your actions.
It goes away right away. You experience
it and you're in a new reality.
All of a sudden I got no house. I found
another place. My life moving forward. Uh,
you keep on getting out of sync with
us for some reason. You're a camera.
And so I'm trying to fix it flashed.
I noticed that it flashed. Yeah. Well,
I'm trying to fix it right now, but long
was the audio is on. I'm going to be,
I'll be a man of mystery,
but it was weird.
It's like me and Greg would be talking
and then you would answer like five
seconds
on delay. So it was like me and
you were in a different world.
Didn't show this really trippy to watch.
I've been,
I fixed it once before then it
started happening again. Yeah.
You think it's because of
switching this laptop? Yeah,
probably switched to Windows. Yeah.
We tried to do the podcast at windows.
The iTunes version will be good. Ladies
and gentlemen, go get that audio version.
And as far as the video, uh, we gave
it a shot. Uh, wait, what is it?
We were broadcasting for the first
time today. It looks like it's, yeah,
I fixed it. I fixed it last
time it started happening again.
This is the first time we're broadcasting
the video portion of it off of a
windows computer when you've done
them before. Why? Because we have one,
we have this Alienware computer that
gave it to us. So we figured, well,
let's try it. Let's try it this way.
Normally you do it a different way.
Normally we do it through a Mac and
I mix it up, points in our head.
We decided,
uh,
we decided to see what would happen and
apparently there's some issues I want to
with the,
that's a fixable thing.
It's probably the power of the
laptop trying to handle three,
uh, uh, webcams at the same time.
So I'm guessing you get a weak ass bitch.
Well,
we went from an Imac, which
is topical line two, three,
three webcams or taken it down.
But that's a gaming laptop.
Those things or they have super power
when it comes slowly. Fix Cards. Yeah,
but wouldn't that have anything to do
with the information coming out of CPU?
I mean, you're doing three
webcams. I don't know.
And it's the power of powering and
here's why it's the wrong one. You know,
I should have brought
that big giant one in.
We should have tried it with that one
because that one is much more powerful
than you think. That would be a good
drive. Yeah. That's a lot of shit,
but there their computer sort of,
we're trying to do this.
Technically we're a mess
trying to do a two camera thing.
Backstab I'm doing a one hour special on,
we're shooting backstage
with multi cameras and trying
to stream it live before
I go on and uh, the directors all on
top of that shit. And I was just like,
you know why
you begin to be doing in the stream?
Just um, you know, I'm backstage, my,
my two best friends that I grew up at,
two biggest fucking troublemakers
because I'm shooting it in Tarrytown,
New York and these guys,
I can't even get into what they fucking
did cause one of them is the town judge,
the other guys, the fire chief is
a fucked up these towns are at. So,
uh,
so the special is going to be me.
They're pulling up somehow illegally
getting firetruck and pulling me up to the
front of the theater on a firetruck and
then at the end they're leading me out
and putting me into a police
cruiser and a tear it down.
So I want to have all my buddies back
page that I used to fuck around with
growing up.
All the troublemakers and just right up
until they announced my name and go on
stage. I just want to be
fucking around and laughing.
That's a great idea. That'll get your
really warmed up. Sort of like a,
when we do the Ice House to the podcast
we do right before we can show exactly.
Same sort of thing.
Probably inspired me to do it actually.
It's a great move a think about it.
Those are the guys that put
you in the frame of mind,
you know that made you a
comedian the first place.
Yeah. You get into the rhythm of making
them laugh and do that to the audience.
That is a, when you get a group of
guys and a couple of them were funny,
it can get pretty fucking crazy.
Yeah.
If you get a group of guys and
a couple of them were funny.
Well cause then you got the guys that
they're laugh keeps, keeps it going.
Then he got the guy you're all shitting
on. Yup. And you all know the dynamic.
It's like a gift. It's like a beetle. You
got four guys and they all have a role.
Exactly. It's hilarious. Who is
your, who is your guys growing up?
Uh,
well,
my two best friends when I was growing
up were two Jimmys and they were both a a
year ahead of me.
So they,
they were graduating and they
were both a tradesman one.
Jimmy's a carpenter and when Jimmy is
an electrician, just real normal guys.
And I lived with a one, Jimmy. Jimmy
did Teleo great fucking guy to this day.
I talked to him every now and then.
I really don't get to see him that often.
I saw him when I was in Boston
when it was there for the UFC.
Him and my other friend Jimmy,
Jimmy lawless.
Hey Sal. Both of them
together. Yeah. Yeah.
We hung out and then they brought
their kids. It's crazy. You know,
Jimmy Lawless brought his kid. It's just,
it's so weird. In Israel. Name is lawless.
Yeah, that's, he's a great guy too. He's,
he's been my buddy since we were like
15 as it just like, like all times.
Oh yeah. He's just a great
guy. Well you know the,
the thing that I've always said about
that life, the living that life in Boston,
it's a hard life to live
in that whether it's a,
it's a hard,
it's a hard place to grow up too because
people in Boston have like extreme blue
collar work ethic too.
There's like a lot of that up there too.
There's a lot of people that like when I
was in high school I felt so lazy cause
I knew like 10 dudes that had landscaping
jobs, they had their own like,
like series of launch. They would cotton
and they were hiring people and this,
I remember this kid was driving a brand
new car when we were in high school.
Like what the fuck? He always had
money. This kid is incredible.
He just figured it out.
I felt like such a lazy asshole because
this kid had figured out how to move and
hustle.
Like there was so much of that and I
grew up in Newton and Newton upper falls.
There was so much of that there.
But Newton is kind of right and
wrong side of the tracks isn't it?
Well,
my side of the tracks was just,
we just lived in a really cheap house
in a pretty decent neighborhood.
I mean it was a cute little neighborhood,
but the houses a piece of shit and my
parents bought the house so that we could
be in the neighborhood so that get us
into a good school system because we were
in Jamaica plain before that,
which was like really shade
the area. Where else? Hey, make
me a fucking Sally's down. Jp.
Jp was shady.
I saw some crazy shit live in there
and just a couple of years it was a,
that was a tricky place. But you know, no,
nothing compared to like real bad and it's
not Compton or anything like that. But
there was that whole like
Italian, Irish, like you had JP,
you had uh, uh, not
Dorchester, but um, uh,
west Roxbury,
not Roxbury,
but west Roxbury right next to JP.
And it was like you weren't in Dorchester
but you could get your drugs there and
you know,
there was,
there was like people that had got just
enough money to get out of the really
shitty neighborhoods,
made it out to like Jane.
Yeah. We would go into Dorchester and
late at night and buy food at places.
And I remember we were at this place,
they were serving like steak
and cheese sandwiches and uh,
it was open really late at night
and this neighborhood was fucked up.
This is like,
it was like you were scared to expose
your money before you paid for it because
you thought someone would just snatch it
from you. Yeah. Like there was just some,
some wild,
crazy people there.
And they had this thick
plexiglass between the,
the server in you and they only served
you through like the slot. And uh,
they gave the guy the sandwich and then
the guy says, that'll be, you know,
x amount of money and the guys just
start screaming hardy page or you
motherfucker, you're trying to cheat me,
you motherfucker. And they were like,
I can't let it go. Let it go, let them
go, let them go. Just let them go.
Just let them go and they just let this
guy creep out on there and just hoping
that he didn't just blast them,
hoping that you didn't catch a
man on his last day. You know,
because you can, if you, you
know, especially if you live
in a big city, we fucking,
I guess you can get anywhere if you just
run into someone on their last straw,
like that guy just run into that guy
and they were like half of the sandwich.
Thanks.
Take it easy.
That's where you got to have instincts.
You know, you can take anybody in a city,
you know, you take somebody who's not
from a city and you put them in a city,
they don't have that instinct.
Don't let him go walk away or challenge.
There's times where it's
just a safe to challenge.
Yeah.
Sometimes with,
sometimes people talk too much and they
get themselves in trouble and they don't
know what a real fist fight is.
Like. They don't know what a real,
there's no rules out there.
Okay. That guy could stab you.
Like you don't even know this guy.
He might be from some other country
where you know they'll stab people on the
regular. I mean, he might fucking shoot
you. You don't know what you're doing.
Why are you fighting people? Like if you
could avoid it at all costs, avoid it.
Yeah.
Paul can be a subtle thing
too. Like when I, you know,
walking through New York
City all those years,
if I'd be fucking lower
east side late at night,
three black guys come from the
other direction. Not to be racist,
but the fucking reality is three
black guys walking past me in a bad
neighborhood. You fucking cross
the street. That's dangerous.
You've got to walk right at them.
You can't make eye contact,
but you don't look away.
There's a subtle way that people know
how to live in cities and if you,
if you fucked that up, you become
a victim. Like exponentially more.
Yes, absolutely. That's what
I mean by challenge. Yeah,
I know what you mean by that. Yeah, I
agree with that. Definitely. What I'm,
it was like people start unnecessary
altercations. I run, I just take off,
let's turn around.
I see a black guy had a cycle,
probably could outrun a black guy.
God was that racist?
What I just said?
No,
no,
because you're,
you're just admitting that white
people are scared of black people.
Yeah.
I'm more of black people and white people.
I can tell you, I mean, if you want
to be fucking totally rip myself open,
to be honest. Yeah, I am.
I'm not, uh, I think, uh,
physically more black
people can kick my ass,
but I think there's more white
serial killer. So interesting.
You're yelling, you're
going cereal. I'm with Greg.
I think a white people are just as creepy.
You're crazy.
I think my fear comes
from what I look like.
I think that as a white guy who's
not big with a receding hairline,
I think I look like somebody
that you could fuck with more.
And I think especially for black
people, I look and that, and it may,
and it's not true, but in my head,
in my fucked up view of things,
I think that they're seeing me that way.
I'm putting that on them. That's good.
Get you in trouble, man. I
got robbed by a black guy,
so I immediately think that you
never got robbed by a white guy.
I'm a white guy. I mean I'm,
I've only, they robbed once. So
hopefully in the future it's a white
person and an Asian person than a Mexican.
So you have a phone, multi racial
profile of people who have offended.
You don't even put that out there,
man.
I'm just to come back to you like the
secret and he's gonna start having hanging
around China town late at night so it
gets robbed there. Drunk pants down.
What am I going? I don't
know. I keep forgetting.
Can you give me directions? Totally
lost here. I'll give you money.
How many dudes are out there doing that
right now? How many dudes are out there?
Just fake drunk and Chinatown.
Yeah. Wow. I'm so drunk.
I might just do anything right now
pretending to pass out after
to let the guy fuck them.
A cop comes over and sees it and you
want to report this? Nah, Nah, I'm good.
Let it go.
How many times do you think cops interrupt
blow jobs on a given night in Los
Angeles?
It's amazing cause they don't even hide.
I mean you see,
you see prostitutes just bobbing up and
down. I wouldn't say it prostitutes.
I was saying someone just being someone
just getting crazy in the car. If you,
have you ever seen people do that?
Oh fuck.
I saw a girl given head while
driving down Pacific in Venice,
driving home from dinner with my wife
and were at a red light and I point to my
wife and that dude is driving an SUV
and all you see is this head and they're
higher than us. I can only see the
top of the head bobbing up and down.
And I look at the guy and he looks at me
and I'm expecting a fucking a thumbs up.
Nothing just looks at me. Look straight
ahead, heads Bob. And, and to this day,
keep his boner. This was five
or six years ago to this date.
Every time we're driving down
Pacific at that spot, I go,
I remember the time you
got check. Yes. I fucking
who's probably scared that you were going
to try to honk and ruin his blowjob,
who's panicking? Felt the
conflict, the IDI conflict.
It was losing his edge.
That's what the porn star saying
when they start to lose it
is there edge, I wonder what that
guy did at dinner. Cause like if I'm,
if I'm on fire dinner, you know, I put
the on my head, I'm getting laughs,
whatever.
Then I'm driving home.
She might hold my hand and I get some
sense that there's going to be action.
But how good was he had dinner that she
fucking started bobbing up and down on
them?
I don't even think it was Dennis.
The one that I saw.
I saw I was in the middle of the day.
It was oddly enough with Kevin James
that we're bringing real life and uh,
and he was right beside us and,
and Kevin spot it at first.
And uh, I was like, Holy Shit.
And Kevin was going to hit,
hit the horn and I talked about
it in though. He was just joking,
but the guy saw us and gave
us a thumbs up. That's guy.
The guy saw us and went like this.
Yeah. You pointed to it and it was pretty
funny. That was my closing pit. Remember?
For fucking years, it was like a
ladies, you've never seen this before,
but here's what we do when he gives a
blow job and then I just start pumping my
fists in the air and doing that.
I closed. I was so embarrassed.
Fitzsimmons killed man at fucking killed.
Wow.
Do you ever go back and think about some
of the shit that you said when you were
on stage?
You Go Wapo well,
you know Jim Florentine just put out a
CD called my first notebook and it's shit
that he was so embarrassed.
He used to do,
we found an old notebook and you went
out and he did all of it in a club.
He's putting down on a CD and
he's promoting, you're going like,
I don't know why anybody would buy this.
This is,
that's brilliant. Oh, that's
hilarious. That is done. Well,
that's not brilliant for everybody.
A lot of people go to all these fuck a
material blows. But for a guy like me,
it's brilliant.
Well, I think it's, it's interesting.
It would be interesting to people
in the same way that like, you know,
you hear the, the like Bruce
Springsteen, there's these tapes,
they're just called them the tapes, the
album. And it was when he auditioned,
the first time he drove in from New
Jersey and a fucking broken down Pinto
brought his acoustic guitar
and started playing, uh,
Mary Queen of Arkansas and all
these amazing fucking songs,
acoustic with different chord structures,
different pitches. And it's like,
it's fucking, it's not as good, but
you're riveted because you're like, wow,
this is, this is the fucking sketch
that led to this masterpiece. So I mean,
not that that would be the
equivalent with standup,
but I think it would be interesting
for people to hear maybe the,
what was the roots of a set they already
know rather than just a bunch of shit
you never did again.
Yeah, for sure. Yeah. If they
could hear it like after the fact,
like this is what didn't make the cut.
This is how the bid evolves.
The problem is when those
intermediate steps get online.
Yeah.
You know,
when you know they get ready to get on
the youtube clip or something like that
or you know, you see it and
go, oh but that's not even,
that's like the beginning of it. It's like
it's just growing. Like they're always,
they're always growing
up to a certain point.
But there's that really
fragile time for a bit.
When you're first doing the first few
times you're doing it on stage and not if
one of those got online, you'd be
like, yeah, that's, that's a steal.
Well, cause a lot of times
you're talking around the joke,
you haven't figured out
the bare construction of it
and you're describing the
joke.
Did it later will become,
yeah. That's a very good
way of putting it. And,
but I think when a lot of people don't
know that are watching standup comedy is
that while you're doing it, you know, you,
you're, you're barely even
thinking about what you're doing.
You're almost like writing it. You're
almost like when you really lock it in,
you know that feeling you get
when you're really killing. Yeah.
You're in the flow. You don't even
feel like you're a part of it.
Like you're witnessing it all happen.
That's exactly what I'm talking about.
The happy thing that that's
the flow. Yeah, well that's
what, you know, the whole,
the idea of being in the moment,
completely zen and locked into how the
universe is expressing itself through,
through whatever the fuck is going on
through either stand up comedy or through
music or through to car racing.
Whenever the fuck it is, man.
It's just that,
that,
that moment when it all works out,
you know,
and you come off stage, there's
nights you come offstage exhausted.
Those nights you come off with twice
the energy is when you went on.
It's like you just soaked in all this
energy and you just fucking ride.
It can last a full day where
you're just buzzing still.
Yeah. It's a, it's a weird Gig, you know.
And the weird thing about a uni is that
we've known each other since we first
started. You know, there's not that
many guys from our little group is you,
me Maguire, Tom Cotter, Tom Cotter,
three finalists. America's got talent.
Powerful. Tom cotter. Good
luck to you buddy. Um, I mean
there's, there's, you know,
not that many guys from that,
that small group of open Miker is that
we were in that like the, the, you know,
you think of open mycosis like classes.
Like this is the class of 1988.
There's a class in 1989 and we
were the 88 guys. Yeah. You know,
and it was an every couple of years it
was a very different brand of comedy that
would come out. Not very different,
but enough that you could detect it.
Yeah. There was challenges and trends.
And what was that Kid's name? Who was a,
uh, no, no, no.
The guy who was a irregular at the,
um,
at Nick's comedy stop.
He was sorta like Nick Depaulo,
but oh,
um,
he became like their regular
guy. Fuck. He's funny as shit.
Funny as shit. He never left Boston. No,
I forget his name kills me.
He's still a killer too.
He is a killer.
And that's the thing about Boston is
the guys that have figured out the,
the sort of formula that works in
Boston but are also an original voice.
It's just amazing how you can,
you can destroy when it's a match
of a comic versus a certain locale.
Like you take somebody like David Cross
and put them in San Francisco, boom,
locked in, they're going to
go for long rides with him.
You go to a, you know, Houston
with somebody like a, you know,
like what Bill Hicks was.
You take a southern and you put them down,
blue collar guy.
You put them in North Carolina,
but you take guys like Nick Depalo or
this guy and you put him in Boston and
it's just, it's explosive. What happened?
It's a match. You don't remember his
name. It's driving me fucking crazy.
It's really funny guy. But he just
stayed, you know, and I'm sure he does.
Well like in Boston, Paul
Nard Dizzy. That's it. That's
it. Beautiful. That's it.
And I remember that
kid was like the class,
I think of 89 I think he came a little
bit after [inaudible] 91 maybe 90 yeah
cause I was gone by I think
90 to 91 or 92 I was gone.
Might've been [inaudible] 90 it might
have left at the end of the day.
It was 91 91 yeah, definitely. But
he was really, really fucking funny.
I'm sure he still is. That guy was,
he was really good. Yes. So edgy.
The Shit don't rip a
hole in the million boom.
And it was like a hammer attack dude.
It was just hammer you over and
over again with another one.
Here's another splash line.
Another punchline. Yeah.
That's the rapid fire Boston style.
It's like the,
the,
the crowds in Boston were so hostile
that you had to develop this like really
energetic, like rapid fire style.
You have to be leaning forward. Yeah.
Mentally you got to constantly be up.
There was no sitting on the stool.
Get the fuck off the stool. Yeah.
Jesus. Sure. An entertainer.
Yeah. There weren't long
pauses. I mean, you know,
you start working the road and you,
you learn the value of a nice go get
a sip of water, fucking let them sit.
They'll kill you. Not Boston,
no way. Stay on the horse.
But it's also the, the, you know,
I find it a very Irish thing is that um,
you don't deserve to feel
good or have any pride.
And so Boston is about stripping it
away from you. So every joke is about,
you know, I go to the, you know, I go
to the fucking a tall both and the guy,
I hand them a 20, he goes,
you've got change. No,
that's your fucking job.
Your job is to make fucking change.
I give you a 20 year.
It's just like any fucking entitlement
is just fucking knock in a cold way.
Just knock the Shit Outta
you. Yeah. Like immediately.
And then there was no dissent.
Yeah.
100% right. There was no, no
entertaining and other sides of an issue.
Cambridge was an odd sort of a club.
Do you remember catch a rising star in
Cambridge, right? It's fucking club ever.
Maybe Tom was a great club
that was run by a site.
Then Robin here was,
who was quite a character,
but he loved comedy.
You left a certain type of be hated me,
but he came and he called me. He ate,
you go in and you audition for the guy
you do 10 minutes and then at the end of
it he either, he tells you right away
he goes, no or yes. And he said, no.
And I didn't give a fuck. I've always had
very thick skin. I go, well, uh, I'd like,
why? And he goes, well, I can either tell
you now or we can go on the back and sit
down and I can tell you exactly why.
I said, yeah, let's go on the back.
First words out of his mouth.
As far as I'm concerned.
You're just another cocky little
Irish puke. That was the beginning.
Wow.
That's fucking racist.
He didn't get racist with me,
but he said that I am everything
that he hates about comedy.
He goes, what you do is everything I hate
about comedy. Wow. And I said, oh, okay.
Well, I just didn't,
we don't like the same.
And then we have this like weird stare
down where he's like, it was a big guy,
thick motherfucker. It was a big guy.
Like I didn't want to tangle with them.
I didn't want to have to scrap with them,
but it was a,
it was an intimidation moment. It was
a, it wasn't a comfortable moment.
I didn't like it.
It wasn't like this is a smart,
friendly guy who should be managing a
comedy club and influencing comedians.
Everything had this heavy
leftists bent to it.
Everything had this
like Harvard socialize.
Yeah.
Barry Crimmins would sit at the bar and
if he didn't like what you were doing,
he would yell shit out at you.
Like he was like the dean of the club.
They were best friends and I love Barry
Crimmins. He's a fucking brilliant,
brilliant guy.
But back then he was drinking a lot and
he and those guys were on a mission to
create a place that they thought
was fertile for this type of comedy.
I was a the catch before ever did stand
up with a friend of mine from high
school,
Diane Derosa,
real nice girl and we're just
buddies sitting in the club.
And your boy Kevin Meeney one on stage.
This is before I ever got onstage myself.
And this was when Kevin
meaning was on fire.
Kevin Meaney was a fucking co rusher,
do Russia core Russia and you didn't
understand what he was talking about.
His big pants were a big pants people
and you'd be Corizon laugh and it was so
ridiculous.
And I remember leaving thinking God I
knew he was funny cause I'd seen him on TV
before but I like five cut five
tonight shows that year. Yeah,
I I but nothing like seeing them
like it's such a completely different
experience seeing a guy like that live
because he's like the silliness is not
that contagious when it comes to the TV.
But when you're in front
of that dude and he's,
he was fucking crush.
Hard to describe.
I saw him in that same club probably,
I don't know if it was the same weekend,
that era,
but when he came in the place was fucking
jammed and he went up there sweating
and a bow tie and a jacket.
I don't care.
And to this day I say when people
say who's the best can be, I say,
nobody has ever made me laugh as
hard in one set as Kevin Maney. Wow,
that's a good statement. I
stand by it. I believe you.
100% I might, I might. I, it's too
far of a distant memory for me to, uh,
to say that mine was just as good,
but I remember being blown away at how
funny it was. It was just so long ago.
He's silly and he would sing that song.
I don't care. And that was his theme.
He did not,
he was going to be this ridiculous
rip fucking torn kind of a character,
rip Taylor, rip torn and rip
tail or rip tail. He was,
the guy threw confetti and acting crazy.
It was like a little bit of an element
of that mixed with the guy who really
understood standup comedy. He was fucking
hilarious. He was in my wedding party,
really was one of my officers. Wow. Yeah.
I grew up in one town over from him and
my dad got him on stage is very first
time because my dad was big
radio guy in New York. Wow.
Kevin was a waiter and waited on my dad
and it would be funny and my dad said,
you should do stand up.
And he was friends with the guy at catch
and he got them on stage his first time.
I remember when we were open micros.
I always thought that was really
fucking cool. Like Holy Shit.
Fitzsimmons actually knows Kevin Meaney
like you actually knew Kevin Meeting.
Yeah.
And when you have problems or when you
were going through things you would ask
like Kevin Meeney questions.
I remember a several times
having conversations where
you are dispensing like
wisdom that Kevin Meeney told you about
standing up and we were talking about it
like, okay, yeah. Okay.
That makes sense. You know,
those early years when you're such an
old blind blabbering fucking moron up
there and trying to like, you
know, it has the seal your way
too. Oh, coconut water in the house.
Yeah, it was um, you know,
it was a time when I really
needed a mentor and he wasn't,
he wasn't a guy that brought me on
the road open and form all the time.
It was just more of like you said,
I could call him anytime and he hears a
guy who was this hot one hour special on
HBO.
Miss Uncle Buck comes out all the money
in the world and I come out to la and
stay with them.
You bought a Chrysler K card.
That's the kind of guy who was
fucking business, you know,
underneath all the silliness. He
was a conservative, simple guy.
So who was advice on comedy?
I especially respect it because I could
see this guy was going the distance.
This wasn't a guy. It was hot. It was
going to flail out, which you, you know,
to this day he's, you know, he's still
out there fucking banging it out.
That's awesome. Now he's out of the
closet and now he's getting know,
Bang it out his name.
I didn't know that he will.
I mean, I wasn't one of those
things where I was like,
well Duh. You know, I thought, oh,
I thought it was straight.
I thought he was straight to a lot of
people he'd been married to. Right.
When you married Roy, give a fuck. What
am I the inquired with the kid? No,
not only married. He met a woman out in
La. Uh, fell in love with her and uh,
called me. It was my babysitter who
lived next door to me growing up. Whoa.
Fucking weird. Is that, whoa. How
old was she? She's probably seven,
eight years older than
me or a Harvard Mba.
Real fucking successful type a personality
and a, yeah. That my dad had died.
Oh, there were a lot to be a fly on that
wall. That's my gene Simmons oppression.
Really? Is that what he says?
Joe Stuck in my innocence
to be a fly on that wall. Is he
currently ever show? I don't know,
man. We were trying to get a campaign.
Have him apologize. Bert Kreischer.
Bert Kreischer was on the x show
with him at Jensen was done,
and he said Gene Simmons treated him
more horribly than any human being he'd
ever met in his life.
And Burt said that it was just like
demoralize him because he was a huge kiss
fan who's a huge kiss fan, who was just
literally, and if you know Bert, I look,
I've known Burt since I
knew I met him back then,
but I've been friends with them for a
couple of years now. He's just a fun,
wild dude. And you, if you misread him,
you might go look at this annoying guy,
man.
I'm trying to relax before my
performance man. And so he a,
apparently it was like super rude to Burt,
which is we can't have,
well we can't have that.
That's not a surprise.
It was any kind of known for
being who he is. He's known,
but I met him and he was really nice.
It also makes me,
yeah,
but you know what that is.
That's the guy who treats different
people different ways, different status.
People get a different treatment.
Well is worse than just being a dude.
I wish I could have a personal experience
to share other than the positive one.
But meeting him was awesome.
Then he came to my comedy show,
him and his wife and his kid, his kid, uh,
got my shiny happy Jihad CD from
iTunes and he really liked it.
So is this thing fucking up again Brian?
And it's just kind of just can't keep up
with it. It just kind of wonky. Right.
We'll switch it back, we'll switch
it. But anyway, he was really cool.
His whole family is cool. They came
to a new year's at the Improv was fun.
But you know when you hear a story like
that where someone's like super rude to
a guy like Bert and like, oh man,
that's so hard to hear. Yeah.
Cause every now and then you
were here a story. Yeah, man.
I met Patrick Swayze one, she was a
fucking Douche bag and they're like,
was it really? Or what are you
really annoying? Which one is it is,
it might be that you might be really
annoying and somewhere along the line you
might've decided that he upset
your feelings and how many, I mean,
have you ever had like those weird,
like people who feel slighted
because artificially slided people?
Yeah,
well they're looking for it because
we're storytellers and we all want to go
back to our town or back
to our friends and go, hey,
I met Joe Rogan and they're going
to go really? What was he like?
And the truth is he said hi to you.
You shook his hand,
maybe said three words and then
somebody else did. Now they got it.
They got to fucking pull from
that a story for their friends.
So if there's a hint of you being
dismissive, they're going up,
they're going to blow it out because then
they've got a connection to you or he
was the greatest fucking guy in the world,
which I never want to fall into.
That can't be it.
I mean I'm total,
I go hang out after the shows in the world
and want to be the guy that I'll take
a picture with you,
but you know what?
Don't put your arm around me while your
girlfriend figures out how to snap a
photo on your phone for the first
fucking time of hugging people. Gregory.
I don't get that fellow big hug like this.
I don't mind the hug.
You know what I like? Is the armpit
on my shoulder, my shoulder. Oh,
the sweat. It just deal, man.
That's what it is. The guys,
he's flunking on you and I
bet your girl can smell it.
I bet it's some sort of a primal
thing too. Especially if homeboy,
he doesn't know any deodorant.
Like if you'd come home and
you're around your wife,
she probably feels like you got conquered.
That's right.
What is this a man on you? There's
man, you shown her. That's right.
Or she doesn't know. She just wants
to fuck you. It's just to know why.
How weird are primal smells
like mean isn't that,
doesn't that which puts women on
the coinciding menstrual cycle,
isn't it an affair mono thing?
Is that right? I believe
it is. I want to say it is.
I might be wrong, but I mean
how, how Prime Hill are we?
Women get around each other. They're
their menstrual cycles all coincide.
So if they all get banged,
they all raised their kids together so
the kids have friends. That's my theory.
Isn't there a thing about how your,
your,
your sperm count raises looking at
houses the fuck are you doing, you know,
what are you doing? I'm looking to see
what the comments are while I'm listening.
The comments,
your sperm count goes up when
you're traveling or something.
Of course you're ready to
conquer a new land. Yeah.
Your body knows it's not around. It's
normal smell. And you, your, your,
your dick gets hard when you go to
pick up your spear. Yeah. Traveling.
You're going to war.
I'm going to kill and your luck
cause we'll be home in three days.
How many people are programmed that way?
How many people from the life enrollment
times we're programmed to kill and fuck,
fuck at the same time. So I mean it must
be really hard to work that culture out,
calm that culture down.
I mean we're talking about the amount of
violence that we see on a regular basis.
Pretty fucking minimal. It can be a
pretty horrific in certain places,
but in America pretty minimal compared
to what it would be like if this was the
sword fighting days. Yeah. You know,
like on a regular basis people had to
deal with some shit that we couldn't even
fucking begin to wrap our heads around
with. Yeah. It was really about power.
It was what can I take and
he would do it with swords.
It would run into a city with sore to
chop everything up and take all the people
and take their goal and it fuck all
their women. I mean nutty shit happened.
And the world, like in nature, you
know, you destroy your, you know,
if you are competing with somebody for
a food source, if you're an insect,
you will start to kill the other insect
or you will find a way to destroy the
food starts for them so that they die.
But it's a weird thing of the,
when,
when people get into tribes,
especially where they become really
synchronized, like as this tribe,
this is,
this is us and we're going to go after
them and they never even would consider
the idea of taking them into
their ranks are like, hey listen,
we're just going to go plunder. What'd
you guys like to come with us? You know,
we could, we could be a big
army, we could all get together.
We'll take them as slaves, but they
never take them on as equals. I mean,
there was a lot of slave
holding back then. I mean,
it must conquer it and you fuck the women
and you took the dude's and say you're
slipped. Yeah. I mean how many people had
to live their life like that? I was lot.
Right.
That was free for how many years did
that kind of shit go on in this world?
Well,
the Old Testament,
the whole fucking book talks about
slavery like it's not even a sin.
It's in actually the seventh commandment
is thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's
wife, thy neighbor's house, I neighbors
donkey or thy neighbor, his man servant.
It's a commandment that
recognizes slavery.
Jesus Christ that wrap your
fucking head around the Bible,
baby.
Wrap your head around the,
it's funny how people choose to
believe in like parts of it. Yeah,
I know.
And the wording of parts of it as if it
wasn't translated from ancient Hebrew to
Hebrew to Roman fucking English,
and it's like,
and you're going to tell me about the
subtlety of the way he said gay people
shouldn't lie together
in 2000 years later,
my favorite is when people tattoo
biblical quotes on their body.
So you're really not supposed to do that.
Like it says it in the Bible,
you're not supposed to get
a tattoo. I'm like, yeah,
but I don't think Jesus meant it
that much. I also think it might be
fall under the first commandment or is
the second about thou shalt not have
graven images. You should not
have representations of God.
And I think by extension,
why are we hiding?
Why do we have fucking crosses with
Jesus hanging off the wall of that you're
isn't that kind of covered by
extension on the second commandment?
Do we want to his,
he is fucking bloody corpse.
So very strange practice to look
at that all the time. You know,
and the idea that you're
being reminded of the deity,
the one perfect being that existed,
oh thousands of years ago
and since then his followers,
her reverted to pedophilia and
fucking craziness and fear. Yeah,
I know. I know this coming that
has a cross on his arm and I don't,
I'm not friends with him,
but he always wears like,
like those like elastic band things on
his arm just to cover it up so no one
knows. Oh really? That's funny.
You get it removed. Yeah,
get a cover up. Maybe he still likes
it and he's hiding it from comics. Oh,
well it could be that some people
get too ashamed of being religious.
A lot of fighters get religious. It's
like he gives them something to, to,
to really lean back on, you know,
something to give them strength.
And you know,
I've always said that I don't have any
fucking idea whether there's a god,
I'm not a religious person,
but uh,
I leave anything up to
the idea of possibility.
I think anything could be
possible. Anything, well,
it definition
of God,
but to think that there's not some
power that orchestrated did miracle of,
you know, like we regenerating
DNA, all that shit. You know,
to think that there's not something that
can tell you that I know how big the
moon is going to be at what point in the
sky and fucking 50 years and be right.
You know, give me a fucking break of
course, whatever you want to call that.
I think that I always just default in
nature is God and fill in the details.
When, when, when I know more
well it,
it could very well be that there is an
intelligence to all of nature that we're
just not capable of, of, of tuning into.
It could very well be the trees and all
sorts of different parts of nature have
some sort of intelligence.
It just doesn't translate into words.
It doesn't try and translate into,
you know,
certain noises that we recognize with
certain images and certain meanings.
It could be some other form
of intelligence and it's,
it's super possible that the reason why,
you know,
we exist in this ever changing
world and this world is, you know,
being more and more hostile to people
is that it kind of recognizes us as a
threat. You know, the you,
if you have to think of this system
has got to be prepared for everything.
Okay?
There's a reason why certain animals eat
other animals and certain diseases kill
certain percentages of the people.
There's like this crazy corrective
system that goes on on earth and we agree
with that up until it gets to people.
We don't ever want to think that Earth
could ever look at us like, wait,
we might be some fucking cold that it
has and that the more we pull the fucking
fish out of the ocean and throw our
garbage in it and the more we pollute the
sky and change the temperature of it and
fuck the whole balance of it up and in
artificially change the levels of
certain things in the environment,
we should expect that the earth is going
to respond to this change accordingly.
It's going to try to push back.
I mean if, if it is intelligent,
if there's some real method to the whole
idea of this whole thing evolving from
hot ball of rock and lava and then
somehow or another acquiring water and
somehow or another
more matters, more elements
and more life forms. Yeah.
Just keep going and going and
going. And it's all it's, you know,
and it goes back to like a turn of the
19th century. There was a lot of, um,
uh,
so a social scientist and England mills
who talked about population naturally
controls itself, wars, disease,
that there is an actual healthy
number of people to be on the earth.
And because of science,
we've been able to just completely fucking
hyper below that number of people to
the point where we've staved
off and natural correction.
We haven't had war in any
real war and a long time.
We haven't had any fucking plague in
a long time. You know the play again,
19th during World War One,
1970 killed one out of three people in,
in Europe including, well the war and
the plate together. And you know, we,
if we had that now, people
would, they'd lose the shit.
People can't even imagine a devastation.
They don't think it's possible.
Whereas numerically,
it's beyond possible.
It's way overdue. Well,
there was a super volcano
warning today, um, somewhere,
God, I want to say that.
I want to say, I want to say
somewhere in the South Pacific.
I don't, I don't really
remember, but there was um,
a warning not to travel to this
particular area because it had been some
volcanic activity. Maybe someone a la, let
me know what the fuck it is on Twitter,
but we had a couple earthquakes at
the California hundreds, right? Well,
it wasn't hundreds. No Shit. Yeah. Well,
there's an area in Yellowstone where they
have thousands of earthquakes a year.
Thousands.
She should ask, not just Yogi
bear chasing boom, boom, boom.
Oh booboo.
What is another guy got killed by a
bear in Alaska and that's where you're
going? Yes. The hardest dark.
The guy who got killed by the bear was a
out there photographing it and standing
near it way closer than what they
tell you too. He was within 50 yards.
Like you should never get within 50 yards,
50 yards. That's, yeah, that seems far.
Yup. Yeah. You should
be far as fuck. Yeah.
You shouldn't make clothes because
you most likely you'll be fine.
But if you get too close to a bear and
he decides for whatever reason that he
hasn't eaten in a while, and you might see
if you're at a ball, if he's desperate,
you can catch a desperate bear,
especially late in the year,
like when it gets close to like December,
you know,
some of those barriers
are still walking around.
Those are the dangerous ones cause
they're not stuffed yet. They're not,
they're not ready to hibernate. That's
how that grizzly man God got got. Yeah,
he went wandering around out there after.
It was like post season when they were,
uh, the, most of the healthy bears
are already in heartland nation.
It's like being in Faneuil hall at two
in the morning when the bars get out.
Exactly. If you're not home, the
ancients, last chance for romance,
you didn't get laid and now you're going
to look for a fight. And that's what,
what happened at two 15.
That one little, uh, what is it? A
fast food place? It a Mcdonald's.
It's on the corner of that.
That was why that hotel that
we used to stay out of it.
We would go to Faneuil hall.
Remember that place that we worked at?
The comedy connection then
it was a chain, you remember
the thing was called Donald's,
but like it wasn't
Mcdonnell Ari and Brian,
Wendy's Ren Brian walked there
and almost got in a fight. Yeah.
Like twice and just waiting in line
everywhere it goes. And you know,
I didn't like Boston the
first, like three, two times.
We went there because we kept on going
to that comedy club in that area.
And then they call it the combat zone.
It's like one bad block and awful.
And then we, the last time we
went, we went somewhere else.
We stayed in this really nice
hotel and they're filming a movie.
There's all these actors in it,
but it wasn't like a totally
different experience.
It was like being in New
York on Monday, we were, um,
we were at the connection and Faneuil
hall wasn't in the comments. Okay.
Wasn't there, but the connection
was, uh, yeah, the, the,
the Wilbur is actually, oh,
like go a way cooler set.
You know,
it's a beautiful environment
and everything like that.
But that area is not,
it's not the dangerous area.
It was when we were doing standup,
like people don't understand the fucking,
they have like a four seasons there now.
You know,
it's, it's a gorgeous area. When
we were coming up and stand up,
it was the combat zone. You would walk
over there, they would be hookers.
It was scary.
You'd see people smoking crack,
you would see peep show booze and they
slowly squeezed all that shit out.
That was like our one CD
area.
I remember I could always park on the
street because nobody would park on the
street that had a piece
of shit because you're,
my window got smashed so many
fucking times. You just were,
you were just used to it.
Yeah. That area around
next man, you got your,
your fucking car got
broken into all the time.
Unless you've got a spot on that street,
on warrant and street.
When you would go around that little side
area where the connection was the old
connection and go down to
the end where Nick's was.
Every now and then he'd catch a spot.
You get super fucking lucky. Yeah.
But that whole area is
a gay bar. No. Do Dude
is detective Byrd.
Uh, yeah, that much with the cubs game.
Like a really a hot gate. Will you let me,
let me get in the back door.
You went with a bug door line,
Fred Sammons cheeses.
Um, but the, yeah, that area. Um,
at one point in time it was uh,
there was two comedy clubs in the same
theater where the same area where the
connection was. There was the
connection. And then above it and my,
my car cat a place, remember that?
I don't remember my Clarks. Yeah.
He had some sort of a comedy club.
It was, it wasn't for a long time.
It was in the same theater that they
used to do the heads like some long ass
running show. One of those fucking, oh,
you're talking about above
the original comedy. Oh yeah.
Upstairs they had some kind
of a nun's you one of those,
he's a little run or some fucking shit
done sense. I think that's nonsense.
None Sanity. Um, and then down
the street you had Nick's,
which had three different rooms,
50 yards away, 50 yards away.
They had an upstairs and then they
had two downstairs, one smaller room,
and then one that was like a disco.
You remember the disco Rome that didn't
really make it that they got rid of the
disco after awhile. It's like too
crazy. But guys would do that.
And then across the street there was
the fucking duck soup at what's now the
Wilbur theater. Duck soup was
the, the idea of a Billy Downs.
And Paul Barkley had this idea to put a
super upscale comedy club and put it in
Boston right there and charge more money
and have only clean comedians. Yeah.
And it didn't work.
It didn't work. But then you
forgetting dicta already had a room.
If you walk then across the
street and through a mini mall,
there was the comedy vault,
which had been a bank. Yes.
And the fucking room was,
the fault was still there.
And you would stand in
this little fucking room.
That was a bag and it was a sweet little
room. It's gray room. But I mean it's,
you're talking about within
literally within a quarter of a mile,
you had even three, four, five, six,
six comedy rooms and they were all
good. Yeah, it's ridiculous. We're
becoming those, those annoying
old dudes to keep repeating
stories about the glory days.
But what people don't understand is just
how, that's by the way, that's a meme.
What people don't understand.
Cause I always say that when I don't know
exactly what am I saying next time is
that the, the scene was just to
us now today, looking back on it,
as you know, you see what's around today.
It's so, it was such a spectacular scene.
It was just the most amazing scene
for like developing as a comedian.
Well you look at like, did you
read the book outliers? No.
It's this book about how people like
Bill Gates came about at a certain time.
They had a certain gift that
wasn't necessarily a good thing.
Like I think gates is mildly Asperger's.
He was born,
he was born in the Santa Cruz area just
as the tech thing was exploding and he
used,
I think it was Santa Cruz,
whatever the UC college had the first
like mainframe computer as a teenager.
He was going in there
and writing programs.
So he was at the beginning of a wave
with the exact personality type and he
carried it through and became
something that you can't do again.
And like Howard stern was
an outlier with radio.
He became the guy who did all the things
you weren't supposed to do on radio,
bad mouth,
other people be dirty self aggrandize
and all the sudden this wave of
syndication of radio stations came about
and he fucking caught that wave and
took and with talent. This is talent
God given fucking, uh, you know,
a weird recipe for what matches the
demands of that time and being in front of
the explosion that happens.
And I believe that we were very much in
the outliers spot of standup comedy by
being Boston at that time.
It was a very unusual
environment for sure.
It's sad that it doesn't exist anymore.
It's when a friend saw me to put out
that documentary when standup stood out.
Yeah. And it's really interesting, but I
think he kind of nailed it is that the,
the scene was fantastic until
people started making it when, uh,
when everybody just wanted to be funny.
You are one of the first
ones. No, no. Yeah,
I remember Joe Rogan cause everybody's
back. They're gone. But you hear Joe,
Joe moved here. Dude, he's, he gets to
do the prompt shows the danger fields.
That was literally like, people
were like me making this shit. Well,
I'm just saying in steps and then
Joe Rogan just signed with a a what?
Jeff's then all of a sudden Joe Rogan
just got out a hundred thousand dollar
deal with Disney and we knew every detail
your fucking career because nobody had
done that before.
Nobody from our class had gone
anywhere really except like,
you know,
I remember a Budd Friedman came to Boston
and did a showcase to do evening at
the Improv and we,
it was like the for months we were
fucking obsessed with our set and a couple
people got it out of it.
And uh,
and that was our closest brush to show
business until you all of a sudden God on
this fucking track. And it was like, wow,
you can do that from this.
So you ruined everything.
That was real.
Well everybody thought for some reason
that the only way you would ever get on
TVs if you were clean.
And I thought the only way I would ever
want to do comedy as if I was funny.
So I knew I wasn't good and because I
wasn't good, my dirty comedy wasn't,
it was unbearable because it's like
not as, it just not, is it offensive?
Not only is it offensive, but it's
also bad. It's bad and offensive,
which is like way worse. Yeah. Yeah.
Well in the beginning I think, I think,
you know, take, took a while for me
to figure out how to do it right,
how to do shit that I
actually thought it was funny,
but I knew I could never do it clean. I
just wasn't going to try. I just was like,
nope. I just, I, I, I fall,
I'll scratch together some little
five minute sets here and there,
but that seems crazy.
Like why would I do that?
Why would I limit what I'm thinking about?
Why it seems like that's like step
one to fucking yourself. You know?
I just got lucky that it worked.
It didn't have to work.
It could have skid off into the fucking
woods and I could have become some kind
of an,
the thing about that time though,
there was no roadmap for it.
And that's what an outlier is.
It's like you're the,
you're a pioneer in the sense that
you're breaking the rules and yet you're
rising up faster than anybody else because
things change and there becomes the,
you know, the needs and the demands of
the marketplace for whatever it is you do.
A, they change very kooky.
They're dynamic and the, and the,
and it's why we have the, you know,
variation and species. It's Darwinism.
Yeah. And it's, I've also felt like when,
when anything happens to that it's good,
then you actually believe
that good things can happen.
So for me it's like believing
that something good can happen.
Like all I could think
of was, well, you know,
if I keep working at this more good things
can happen. Like I'm on a roll and I,
I don't want to stop this role.
And so I think, um, you know,
when you're a young guy and you know,
your life has been like
Kinda like half sketchy,
filled with a lot of fucking failures,
all relationship failure is all like,
oh,
just different failures
that you go through and then
you're on stage and you're
trying to do comedy.
Like just trying to make sense
of that aspect of your past.
When you look back on your,
your life of being an open miker
and that the wild experience of,
you know,
trying to fucking do that for a living,
it doesn't even feel like
it's you does it, I mean,
doesn't it feel like it's a lie,
you know, it feels like you're,
you're accessing memories that were copied
a hundred times over and they're real
shitty and you like,
I think it was this Guy Larry Rowe
poochie yeah, yeah. Larry Alario Gucci.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
And I think I wore shirts that had zipper
is going down the arms and I think I
had a mullet and I think I did a joke
about what I do and girls are calling me
and none of it's,
and,
and I also look at it like limitless
fucking energy and passion.
I would tape every set, rewrite it.
I would fucking drive me anyway.
We would drive all over the fucking
place. It was, there was no limit.
And then I'd get up at the crack of dawn
and do fucking banquet waitering and
then I would go audition for some
cold call bullshit downtown. I mean,
there was not like now
where I got to pace myself,
pick my battles back then it was no,
every fucking battle I'm in. Yeah,
and somewhere
along the line I think
as a standup comedian,
you forget that this
was a terrifying time.
Like those times that you
talked about were terrifying,
but might've been the most exciting
moments of your life, you know?
I mean the, the, the first couple
of sets that you do that are good,
that feeling when you're like, holy
fucking shit. I think I'm onto something.
And then you become obsessed.
Did you want to write things down
everywhere you go? Because yeah,
I went to college and to me it was like
I was told what to do and how to thank
for four years there were tests on a set
of information I was supposed to learn
and internalize and believe.
Then you're going to stand out and it's
a blank slate. It's what do you think?
Would you believe when you make that work?
And all of a sudden I felt in a way like
that made me grow up in six months more
than I did in four years in college
because it was all my creation.
Yeah. Yeah. Well that's one of the most
important things about, uh, you know,
really finding yourself as putting
something down and been able to look at it
and go, I fucking, I got that. I did dad.
I got, this is an actual thing that I did.
Like, here it is, it's put, I put it down
and then you can move on from it. So easy.
So much more easy. You
get more momentum. Yeah.
Did you ever read the war of Art Steven
Pressfield Book? What's it called?
The war of art now you told me about
that, dude. I've got a copy for you. Yeah.
Yeah.
Brian,
by the way,
I want to on the air.
Thank Joe Rogan for one of the best
gifts I've gotten in the last fucking 10
years. Uh, a beautiful, I'm
going to mispronounce the name,
aerial Carmeli Aerial Carmeli
pool cue. And I am a, I am a pool,
just an addict my whole life. And uh,
I've, I haven't had a pool cue and about
15 years.
So under that shelf down there,
there's two books to see him.
It's the war of art during the
corner. Can you reach it and no, no.
You Yoga doing bitch. All right. I'll
find it. I'll give it to you after a show.
Remind me there. It's there. Right there.
He just can't reach over. He's impossible.
It was a cop down the Canyon de Chelly.
Oh yeah.
He would already be talking
that who'd already, we
know Brian. It's okay. Don't get it.
It's no, no, no, no. It's no big deal.
It's the most passive aggressive thing.
Yeah. Shit from the other side. Right.
All right man. Just leave it there.
Yeah, don't worry about it man.
I totally cool with it. I'm
really happy with it. No big deal
right next to you. No, no, no.
There you go. That's the book.
I bought a bunch of copies just to give
it to me like it's got dust all over it.
Yep.
I love it. Break through the blocks
and when your inner creative battle,
fuck yeah.
It's a great book. All right. I love it.
It's a great book for like creativity
and I'm sort of getting past the
roadblocks of, um, procrastination.
Oh fuck. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Somebody showed me, this one's been
very interesting work. The guy stuff you
kind of read and then on each thing.
Yeah. Well, you know, it's an ethic.
The guy provides an ethic and he's
got a new one called turning pro,
which is just as good. I just got into
that. But he's a very inspirational dude.
You know, I, uh, I love hearing
about dudes who work really hard.
I don't like hearing about guys who
would come crazy and become obsessed and
become unhealthy,
like they work too much.
But I like hearing about dudes
who have like a great work ethic.
Like could always,
like whenever I hear about Louis C
K putting out a new hour every year,
I always like, I love hearing
that. That's inspirational to me.
I felt like I get like some energy out
of that. Like, Ooh, look this palsy.
Um, it's too much for me. It
turned out I did a, I did mine.
Then I did another one in the little
less than two years and that's why I was
doing like a lot of the UFC stuff as well.
I do less UFC stuff now than I did before,
so it was while I was doing that,
but I still feel like I like to
have a bit around for awhile,
like a year or some stuff.
Bets are fucking thick too.
I mean,
it's not like you write a free standing
joke and have to write another,
I mean you,
you find something and you explore it
and you extend it and then by the end you
got to chunk. That's 10 minutes. So
you string together six of those.
You've got an hour
and I, I, you know, I know there's
like more life to shit sometimes,
but it's like I put some stuff on a
special before and then right after it's,
and you're like, oh, you motherfucker,
the punch line of punchline comes out,
you know, the tag line, it
changes the whole thing.
Dana Gould's just gave me a tagline that
took a bit that was already killing and
doubled. It really, I get this bit about
how we, uh, waste water in this country.
How we just have fun with it. It's
like a joke. We Have Waterpark,
we have fountains which just
shoot water in the air. Like,
fuck you look at all this water.
And then Dana's tagline was,
and then what do we do?
We take money we don't need and we throw
it in the fountain and on top of always
killing that tagline,
just like instant applause,
right? So true. That's a
perfect like description of, uh,
like ridiculous opulence.
Giant fountain. Well,
see what you could dip in and dip
your feet in. Sit in front talk.
It's like a kid with a pot in his
lap and it's, it's like he's pissing,
you ever see those pissing out of it?
I saw a house in Montecito once, you
know Santa Barbara? Yeah. That was,
these people had like, they must
have owned a museum or some shit,
but they had a fountain that was so big.
They converted it into a
swimming pool was fucking huge.
This huge gorgeous fountain
was a swimming pool.
These people have like
three fountains as houses,
ridiculous like that Monosito
area of Santa Barbara.
It's like some of the most gorgeous
houses like you've ever seen. You're like,
Oh hell yeah.
Perfect weather all year round.
They're looking over the ocean and
you're like, Holy Shit. Anytime
I'm in that part of the world,
you go down below San Francisco,
they got to think all
the seven mile drive,
which is where like Pebble Beach Golf
Club is and I really do think that there
is not a more beautiful place. I
mean, I haven't been to like Tuscany.
I'm sure there's places,
but I feel like you can actually afford
to live in a place along the code,
the Jag, California coast where the
weather is fucking perfect. All the, it's
just peaceful people and I sort
of feel like, why not do that?
Teach school
each school, what would he do?
And living in a fucking movie.
We're going to learn how to bake bread.
Yeah, I lost it. They're faking shots are,
that's crazy.
There are some places like Carmel,
like you ever been to word those were
Clint Eastwood was the male is right below
where I'm talking about. Oh is
it right below that? Right there.
So fucking beautiful. It's so
beautiful. You get hot, cold
town. It's all like art galleries
and cafes that are fucking, you know,
international and it's bad.
I mean,
but it's one of those things where hope
you like white people cause that's all
we got here.
Rich white people.
Yeah. That's a real white town, right?
Old White people. That's all public. Yeah.
Yeah. He said some crazy
shit at the Republican. Oh,
he's losing his marbles for sure.
Right.
Hey. Well it's like, it's tough
because those John Wayne type guys,
they come from an era where you know men
were manly and it was simple and it was
black and white and it's just a
different world now and you try to, you,
you can't shake clinics was
not going to not be that guy.
But the times dictated different,
more layered approach to things.
I think he's missing a substantial amount
of what he used to have as a young man
as far as his intuition on
how to do things correctly.
He just doesn't seem, he
didn't seem there. It seemed
like a big struggle to me.
That whole thing where he's bringing in
John Voight how much on my shelf it was.
There was something weird
about it. You know, the,
just all the crazy talk about him being
a conservative and it'll conservatives
and we just try to, you know,
play our cards closer to our vest.
Like what are you getting wrapped up with?
Are you,
do you really believe this narrative?
Do you really believe this or are you
actually paying attention to what you're
supporting by being there,
pretending to talk to a chair.
Like if you talk to the
president like that,
he should have beat the fuck out of here.
He should box your ears.
Who the fuck are you to talk to
the president like that credibly,
that whole fucking
thing was just negating.
None of it was putting
out here's our real,
here's our plan for the
economic recovery specifically.
All it was was tax cuts and more shit.
We're going to give you stuff that adds
up to negative and yet they're selling
it by by basically dismantling
what already existed.
Like everything was a negation.
There was no positive energy about it.
Yeah.
It's a weird thing to watch this all play
out to watch this Mitt Romney guy and
to see this, this whole situation.
It's really weird. It's weird.
It's weird to watch it play out man.
As Paul Ryan Dude has already been
busted line on all sorts of shit.
He said he ran a marathon in
less than three hours. Yup.
That's like world class.
They could they,
they timed it and it was four hours over
four hours over an hour in New Yorker
did this piece last month about this guy
who was a serial marathon liar and he
had a website about raising money for
kids with fucking down syndrome and
support them.
This guy has a dentist in a small town
in Michigan who everybody loves and he's
got this whole reputation about being
this marathon runner who's going to run in
all 48 states in, in the
continental us, and he's going to,
he's going to do a marathon and each one
is going to post this. His results, well,
they're starting to be a couple
questions about that. He hadn't, they,
there was no pictures of him
in the middle of certain races.
There is a fearsome marathon contingent
that that tracks every single marathon.
One of the things I have is
these chips and you have to,
you have to hit I think three chips during
the race to to prevent the rosy ruins
thing for someone jumping in a car.
So they went back and
they looked at the chips.
He fucking hit all of
his chips in everyone.
But then there's pictures of
them in different outfits.
There's races where there's no pictures.
There was one race.
He actually made up what?
He just made up a range. No,
but he posted that he wanted to have
a San Jose Marathon. Nobody responded.
So, so he posted 10 with 10 people
that finish in a certain time,
made up the names, put them on the
website and had him as the winner. Oh,
that's hilarious. So He's, so anyway,
they unraveled it and it
was just more like it was,
the piece was just about
how people can get,
what is it called when you lie and you
have no, you have no guilt about it. Um,
sociopath, sociopath, like this
is a sociopath about marathons.
Everything else in his life was
totally fucking straight up. Good guy.
Except this crazy man.
And so the point being there was a very
clear record with Paul Ryan of how La,
there's no discrepancy.
There's no, you know,
he absolutely ran it in four
hours and 10 minutes to set it.
Still Pretty fucking good.
Really? They say that's average.
I think that's pretty good for
a guy that looks like that.
It's like an 11 minute
mile. Amazing. Didn't quit.
Quit all the marathon.
Amazing. Made it through. Yeah.
It's a hard thing to do. My
amazement, anybody runs 26 miles.
But why lie about the time when four
hours on still pretty fucking good.
He's trying to pretend like
he's like a super athlete.
Well that's the problem is
that if he lies about that,
tell me it's a character thing,
period. What if he's lying about that?
What else is going to lie
about his numbers for the
economy are a fucking joke.
They'd been debunked by
bipartisan committees in
Congress because he introduced
this whole new economic recovery plan
and it was looked at and they said,
this is horse shit.
This does not add up.
But he had every Republican lined up
because he was the new hot shit in in
Congress when he came in as a junior
senator. What is his strategy or his
philosophy that he's going to do?
It's different.
What was his idea?
Well,
it's real and rand this guy,
so it's pure free market.
There's no regulations and a you the,
you know the,
it's letting capitalism basically dictate
everything and it's about getting rid
of the safety net entirely.
He wants to take apart Medicare.
He wants the entire new healthcare
program taken, taken away.
He wants to prioritize social security,
which again has been shown in study
after study after study is a worst case
scenario.
You're taking a fund of money that people
have paid into with a very nominal,
uh, broker with service fee, you know,
built into a 0.04% or whatever and you're
saying, okay, everyone grabbed theirs,
give it to a broker who's
going to take 5% your bloating,
this one industry because
they've lobbied you. That's all.
That's all this is about.
Banks want to be able to get their hands
on this money and crank up commissions
in, in making the investments for
you. That's all this boils down to.
Ran into a, due to one
of my shows who, uh,
is an Iraq war veteran and he went in,
he actually volunteered for the army
and then right after he volunteered,
um, I don't remember which
branch I said the army,
I might be wrong or right after,
I think it was actually the air
force right after he volunteered,
nine 11 happened. So right afterwards
he's going to war. And, uh,
he'd said that one of the first things
that the United States government did was
they printed Iraqi money,
just fucking crazy amounts of it and
just flooded the market with fake money.
And that's how you're crushing economy.
Is that amazing? Like, you know,
wanted to crush our economy.
They would just make,
just put millions and millions of dollars
like in the streets and people would
go crazy and run out and buy Ferrari's,
Ferrari's, it'd be worth nothing.
Anything that happened here. Do you think
that's a, could it happen here? I, yes.
Look, the, the, the economy
is not based on anything.
That's what the idea of a gold standard.
That's where it's supposed to make some
sense. And the idea though that you're,
you're going to be able to make something
like a dollar bill that can't be
reproduced by somebody with
nefarious means. Of course.
They're going to be able to figure that
out. Man. As technology gets better,
they're not going to be able to hold off
the, that whole printing press thing.
People are going to figure
out how to make money.
To this day, the, uh, I forget what
the Iranian and Iraqi currency is,
but a DNR I think. Yes, exactly.
It is the lowest rated
currency on the planet.
It's like a hundred thousand per $1.
What do you do then? Do you have to
start from scratch? You have to start.
The whole civilization
got to go to the gold standard.
I mean it's,
you got to find something to tether it to.
Yeah. And then by then the militaries
in the streets and you're fucked.
I scramble.
Yeah. You know what's amazing is
you're talking about Mesopotamia.
You're talking about the most fertile,
the origins of all civilization.
And it's a fuck zone.
It's amazing. Well, I've, I think
they're the townies of the world.
I think that's what it is.
They just been around too long.
That's where civilization was invented.
So that, that area, that's the,
sorry,
same assholes who developed their
civilization 6,000 years ago.
They just stayed. Everybody else is
like, these people are fucking crazy.
They're throwing rocks at people
for dancing. Let's get outta here.
So every other civilization
branched off from that one part.
But they stayed and they got, yeah, they
got two story. I got a double decker.
I'm fucking rent out the upstairs
to my parents. Do you want,
when you go back to Ohio,
do you relate to townies or do you think
that Ohio is like a better place to
live? Did you go back and forth? Boring.
But I mean if I could have
a humongous house, you know,
and people live great there.
Everyone has, my sister has two kids,
works as a hairstylist,
but she has a huge house and a huge yard.
So it just seems, it's weird.
It's easier and more comfortable.
It's not as stressful.
It's not,
it's weird how much variation there is
and areas where you could buy a house
variation. The money, like who
she, you know, I'm so white
you can get, and you know,
another thing was is like when you walk
to your car at night and when you do
certain things,
you automatically feel safe out there.
Like you could just sit there and just
have money in your both of your hands and
walk to your car after going to a movie.
And no one would give a shit dude,
from that video that you made,
that dude who went to the 100 best videos,
by the way, the Heckler, the drunk heckler
and Columbus. Oh yeah. Remember that one?
Yeah,
dude, that was first of all,
that was a awesome video.
You may cause you the way you
edit it was so funny. It was just,
the dude was so ridiculous.
But we missed the best part of the story
because this guy who had his shirt off
and my comedy show screaming,
yelling. Yeah. Yeah.
I came off stage and I hugged him.
It was like the most ridiculous shit of
all time. He was just like so hammered.
He was so crazy.
We ran into him at the end of the night,
face covered in blood shirt lists.
Just somebody beat the
fuck out of this guy.
And I looked at him and I
looked at them on, sorry dude.
Yeah, but we didn't, we didn't
fuck it filled that need to know.
No one had anything on. So we were like,
Shit. Yeah, I saw this dude. I was in. Um,
and Jose, if you do that fucking club
in San Jose, the Improv. Oh yeah.
Fucking amazing. I'm supposed to
do it sometime soon, but the, the,
the show got moved.
It was a for,
I was going to do the
Friday night before UFC.
Places like a 500 year
old ancient theater,
three Charlie Chaplin perform
their cheese and acoustics.
You don't even for 500 years old.
I'm just making shit up.
There weren't people in California
five and years ago. Stupid.
What would the ass tax doing? A
standup show. Isn't that weird?
That just 500 years ago
there was no people.
And you've got to Europe and
you'd like to talk about Iraq.
It's like they got a history.
Yeah,
that's San Jose Improv is one of the
most beautiful interiors, like the,
the inside and the feel of
it. Like it feels like, uh,
like a seasoned performance room,
well worn room and the guy that runs a
jam is fucking treated me great. Anyway,
professional bowler. Yes.
Bad mother fucker. He was a
Vietnam vet too. Good too.
He a, he goes bowling and just
fucks people up apparently.
Apparently he's like legit worldclass
bowler and he'll go to Vegas and people
gamble in Vegas, you know, they get
crazy. They're out there on vacation.
Well it's called ball a few frames.
They start talking shit and you know he
comes over and he knows how to him until
he knows how to play their ego.
And he starts getting involved in a big
gambling with some knuckleheads and he's
come back with like
sick money from gambling in Vegas.
Yeah. And he's such as fucking
cool guy. Just unabashedly
the real deal. Cool.
Just a cool guy. Yeah, he's a,
and you know he got fuck man.
He went to Vietnam three and a half years,
came back,
did his 21 years in the navy
and now he's like, yeah,
I get 120 bucks a month and
fucking benefit. He goes,
they cut all the benefits that you're
promised and including like going to the
Va hospital and get, get your glasses,
dental, all that. Shit's gone to do that.
That's my, what the fuck.
You get pro, you go to war,
you put your life on the
line for the country.
You are fucking taken care of period.
That that is the biggest
travesty happening right now.
Some UFC fights, we did it for the, some
institute for traumatic brain injury,
I believe it's called and it was there.
They're building some huge thing
so they had to raise money for it.
So the UFC fights raised
a lot of money for it.
But one of the things I was thinking of
was how crazy is it that there's these
billion dollar deals that these people
like Halliburton and these companies
around there like Halliburton get
billion dollar deals in in it somehow or
another is not the money
for these rehabilitation
centers. Like that's insane.
The fact that they can profit off the war
and not be giving anything back in the
form of some,
at least you know,
do what what a charity is doing.
At least do that.
I mean you're profiting from
the charities just stepping in.
That's exactly why it's privatized because
the u s government allows itself to
be buffered from number one.
If there's a rape overseas eat,
doesn't it? It does not get
processed in US courts. They've got,
they've got all illegal
people work in the jobs,
they tit tell these
girls in the Philippines,
the Halliburton does through
another agency that they get it,
they're going to get a job
doing hairstyling and they're
going to make 40 grand
a year. They take them off and they're
working at fucking burger king in the mid,
in the Mideast sleeping in fucking
tankers and paying off the money.
They had to pay to get over there for
like five or six years before they make a
dollar and slavery. Yeah. It's
fucking slavery, slavery word.
They'd just, they have it written down
somewhere. So it's like okay to do. Yup.
Somehow or another,
cause it's not the US government because
the US government is sub contracting to
Halliburton so that you
know, any kind of, uh,
any kind of lawsuits that come in,
don't they don't touch the u s government.
And so they,
so they're not paying out to the soldiers
because they have no real relationship.
You slavery without chains, just
make it so they can't leave. Yes.
May mean you might lose one or two every
now and then, but you can get them back.
You can get different ones and it's
a terrifying sort of a situation.
But that's like a lot of what's going on
apparently in parts of the Middle East
in like Dubai or did that gone on
and some uh, construction sites,
I think didn't vice do
a special on that Brian?
I don't know. Yeah, they said if he buys
things do by, brings in people from, um,
I don't know.
I can't remember what country it is,
but they bring them in on these,
they're not even,
they're like work visas that are like
a week long and the second you're done
with your work, you're gone. It
just, you don't earn your way in.
And so that's something like,
you know,
three quarters of the work force is not
from that country and they just have
these sprawling fucking
camps that people live in.
And then they kicked him out
as soon as now instantly. No,
no coverage in accidents whatsoever.
It's barbaric.
It's fucked up too, because again, we're
talking about the townies of the world.
So they really still are rocking it the
same way they did a thousand years ago
or several thousand years ago. There
really are rocking it like that. Yeah,
just rocking it like that. Behind the
rules. I mean, they really do steel,
it's still have kings and uh,
there was some piece on, on, on um,
that dude, um, who, uh, we had
Brian on the podcast the other day,
David Seaman, he had something that's
his real name, powerful dude though.
He's a great guy. That
is his real name. Um,
and there was something that
he had on his Twitter page.
It showed how CNN had some stories about
the Arab spring uprising in Bahrain and
they decided not to aerate and uh,
apparently about rain is fucked up and
people start to make youtube videos of it
and put them online because there's
not enough interest in, you know,
there's so many, everyone's aware of Saudi
Arabia, everyone's aware of, you know,
what's happening in Egypt.
Everyone's aware of Libya,
but a lot of people are
not aware about rain,
so they're still trying to
keep this one locked down.
And while everything else is going on,
but there's some horrific fucking foot.
Yeah,
and it's just government controlled media.
man. They're gunning people down
there trying to stop a civil uprising.
It's horrific stuff, man. Horrific stuff.
And there's really graphic
videos available on,
and our interest in the average
spring ended about a year ago.
People don't even know what's
going on is worse than any of it.
And people aren't even fucking
tracking that because it's like we, ah,
we already had Egypt, we already
had Libya. Where we've got our Phil,
what people don't understand
is the pocalypse is here.
It just hasn't reached California with
the apocalypse of you're in Bahrain,
that's the apocalypse.
If friends are getting their heads blown
off right next to you by sniper rifles,
that's the apocalypse. I mean, this is a
civil war. People are dying in the street.
The government is gunning down
civilians. I mean, it's craziness.
But what about the places that like Egypt
that now has democratically elected do
there really, isn't it? The
Muslim Brotherhood, they
were voted in and they're,
you know what? They're not
as bad as people think as
they say. The sound rather.
They sound scary. You know what
though? It's one of those things.
Where are they going to snake it in?
They get an office, everything's cool.
I'm gets a Turkey at Thanksgiving.
Two years later the women are
all in fucking potato sacks.
I wonder how much longer that's going
to work with the Internet with the
distribution of information
that we have right now.
It gets harder and harder to convince
kids of nonsense. It's harder and harder.
It's just not the same sort of animal
that was around when we grew up. Lou,
when we grew up, you know even if you
didn't believe in God but made no sense,
you hedge your bet one on one with
everything and you know you believe it is
real.
I did all that Shit I was supposed to do.
Even if you don't have a
whole ton of faith in it,
you don't have the kind of access to
him or we didn't rather have the kind of
access to information
that kids have today.
Cause if they have a question about
anything, like why is the sky blue?
They Google, why is the sky blue? I
mean kids are growing up doing that now.
So they ever have a car,
you can't just bullshit them.
Yeah. You're assuming the internet
stays is free as it is now.
I mean you just by saying Google,
you know,
so many people get their
information from two portals.
You've got Wikipedia and Google
and if those are, you know,
Google is part of a
multinational corporation and
eventually they're going to
rein it in because of corporate sponsors
are because the same pressure CNN gets
to not put out stuff about Bahrain.
Any big company is,
is ultimately going to be effected
by the people that are running it.
Did you hear that? Some of those
leat hacker dude's hacked into a, uh,
an FBI laptop and found the names
of a hundred of no 14 million,
uh,
apple ios users.
They found the information on them.
I don't know what station three they
cracked into that database and got all
those names. It's fucking crazy.
Index box. Well, cause they chair the,
what's crazy is challenging and
they said you'll never crack.
That was either playstation,
Xbox that challenged the hackers.
Basically they can get
through anything. But the, um,
the, what was scary about it
was that these, you know, this,
this whole hacker thing like really
wasn't really recognized. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean when like when you see
like that Guy Kevin Mitnick, you know,
that guy is, do you know what that guy
is? He was like a really famous hacker.
He was a guy who at one point in time
they offered him a job eventually at one
of the big companies who would do like
what's called phone freaking or you um,
phone freaking you'll like you,
you figure out like how to get, um,
make calls through like a box that
would send a tone down the line.
This is like the step one.
It's like the hacking the system.
It's like back when dial tone
phones came online when diet was,
see before dial tones. We all remember
when you were really little kid,
you had to spin that dial, which is
really like alien to people today.
But when you dial a number you'd go
down a lodge.
It was ridiculous. And then they
came out with a dial tone situation.
But what someone realized somewhere along
the line is that there's a computer or
something interfacing on the other end
that's responding to the tones and those
tones represent a number.
So let's find out what those tones
represent and then we could fucking do
whatever we want. And to have access to
free unlimited long distance calling.
Because remember back then you
couldn't get long distance.
Long distance was hard.
Yeah.
Like if you dated a girl and she lived
in the five Oh eight, you'd be like,
oh Jesus, she loves way the
fuck over there. It's the
long distance and then any,
any sort of a state crossing state lines,
long distance.
That was a long distance call.
Your fucking parents
would scream with you. You're a long
distance. It could be 10 miles away.
Remember it used to have held a separate
long distance company to like at and t,
but I had sprint as my long distance.
Right. Spring can save your money.
Do you remember when,
um,
they used to have it for cell phones
were long distance for cell phones.
It's like super expensive. Crazy.
Do you remember that was crazy.
He'd use a calling card,
which meant you had to punch in about
16 numbers before you put in the number
you are calling. Yes, exactly.
Yeah, I remember that. But this, uh,
this Kevin Mitnick guy,
he started out doing that and then
eventually it went to be in some sort of a
full blown hacker.
But to go from that to be
able to experience what's
going on right now must be
like really incredible to witness.
Well there's a group that
he is actually opposed to,
there's a group that identifies itself
as the somethings and they are an
international web of hackers
that get off on doing it.
And they've done every talking about
low sec, is that what it's called?
That's one of them. There's a sec. Yeah.
And he came out against
anonymous because he,
for him cracking the codes
was about the science.
It was about the art of doing it. And
these guys are much more into sabotage.
They have a political
agenda, you know, they,
they out corporations and they
blackmail them. And so, um, you know,
the bottom line is you're never going to
get the talent on the payrolls that is
going to be out there because
they're independent minded people.
There antiestablishment
people they don't want,
they don't want to be in a
payroll because they don't,
they don't wanna be told what to do.
They offer,
they offer this guy a job and he went to
Microsoft or one of those big companies
for like six months. They basically
wanted them off the streets.
They wanted them in house and he
just got bored and he fucking left.
Well that was the,
the,
the big issue was that why did the
FBI have these 14 million ios users
information? Why they have that
on their laptop. That's like what,
how much to what extent is
spying already going on,
on almost every American civilian.
Cause it's probably gotten
pretty fucking crazy now.
Do you feel like when you're making a
text message that you're sending it to the
government as well? Eh,
cause I saw my Dick,
they've seen me talk about
fucking farts a, I mean like what?
I'm not worried about
anything. I understand that
you're not worried about it,
but do you understand that giving people
that kind of access to information is
not, it's not cool. The more they,
why should we agree that they should be
the ones who are allowed to look at all
this stuff and be fair at this data?
I think that's ridiculous.
It's ridiculous to allow someone to be
in that sort of voyeuristic position and
not, I mean look at look at anonymous
or look at any of these hacking groups.
They, those files when they had,
when people hacked like playstation.
It's something that if you were in the
right circles you would be able to have
that file, you know, and like you can
doubt, what are you trying to say?
Like it's,
it's if you wanted information,
like if you want it all this information,
you yourself could get it right
now if you went online,
like if you wanted all these peoples
ps three names and numbers are Oh Ios,
six informations,
you know the FBI got an online also,
you know there was what your sites
download all this information off of
this torrent websites where you can
download stolen formation. Real
absolute. So what are these websites
since this FBI like guy,
he could have his job,
could have been like going to torrent
websites and downloading shit. You know,
he might have also had beauty and the
beast and three d, You know, on his,
on his laptop. You know,
who, who knows, who cares?
I mean like if they're going
to single you out, they,
they're going to single you out.
Absolutely appreciate your,
um,
you're not wanting to get upset at the
experience and like, who gives a fuck?
I'm not doing anything wrong.
But the real problem is you give people
too much power and they fucking abuse it.
And that's why there's
all these psychological,
like fail safes that are set up
in door system that, you know,
you're not supposed to
have too much power.
It's supposed to be like a whole
checks and balances system.
Make sure that people don't get out
of hand because they do naturally.
And if someone all of a
sudden can check your phone,
someone all of a sudden can read
all your emails, they're going to,
yeah.
And the bottom line is right now that
seems safe because there's no imminent
threat,
but you see a guy like Rick Perry become
president and load up the fucking FBI
and CIA,
they're going to go,
we want the Christian values protected
in this country and they're going to
start going after the guys that put
their dicks online and you're going to be
fucking, you know, I'm not going
to be rounded up. You're good.
They're going to on a miss his way more
intelligent than the government and
they're hackers are way better
than shit will take over.
Eventually happen.
It's a fascinating idea.
The idea that the civilization will be
taken over through the inlet and that the
Internet is because everything is
going to be run through the Internet.
They would figure out some way of having
a constantly changing code that you can
never crack and they use it to just
manipulate wealth. And then if you,
as long as you keep your shit together,
they keep everything running smooth.
Yeah. But look what we did. Look I
Israel did to Iran's Internet, you know,
they fucking blew it up. They were
able to crack every, you know,
and we're talking about the most intense
firewalls that that could be put up by,
you know,
a pretty wealthy country.
I ran and they got in there and
they fucking destroyed everything.
And I think you're right,
there's gotta be a fail safe in place
for every country and an overall scheme.
I mean, there's no way somebody who's not
had the foresight to put that stuff in.
It's kind of
kind of amazing when you stop and think
about the ultimate goal of all this
stuff is to connect us all on
some really fucking strange way.
No,
the ultimate goal of all this technology
technologies that there's not going to
be any privacy in a decade.
The one exist.
That'd be something that we
look back on when we were kids.
You're going to be able to go,
I want to rent this six
foot like room or whatever,
uh, two years ago at three 15,
seven, you know, uh, here's
the date. You're gonna be able to
take the date, the time and go,
I want to see video and hear sound of
what happened in that room. You will be,
I bet eventually will be.
Well you know the idea that has been
proposed is that if you get a computer
that's strong enough and wrap your head
around this because it was really hard
to fucking absorb that.
If you get a computer that's strong
enough to record everything that has
happened in this world, like every
person that exists in this world,
every business has been created and
put all of this into a data bank and
extrapolate over a period
of no more than you know,
x amount of days or hours did.
If this computer with given enough data,
giving the, the knowing the
characteristics of all these people,
which eventually there'll be no room,
there'll be no limitations when it comes
to processing power and no limitations
when it comes to storage space.
You literally will be able to store
everything that ever happens and that this
computer would just,
a few weeks of data might be able to go
backwards mathematically and tell you
the absolute accurate
origins of life on earth.
That it might literally by studying
things, not just on a physical level,
but like on a subatomic level,
that this might be enough information
that they could figure out pretty
accurately what happened.
Like how a human being even
came from the primordial slime.
How it got to be a human I give it might
be able to show you the, you know, the,
the birth of culture and it
might be able to show you with a,
with a supercomputer, like what's
caused all of this? Like what,
how did this start caused
that and that cause this,
like it might be something that you
could figure out mathematically.
Well, what's amazing is that how
slow evolution is. I mean, you,
people think physical. I mean,
physical evolution takes so long. You,
you can't even wrap your head around the
amount of time that it would take for
hair to not grow on your nose.
You're talking fucking millions of
years of time for shit to really happen.
So it's,
you
know what's crazy?
Not always man.
One of the things that
they're finding out is it.
In some instances it takes place
much quicker than they expected.
Like in the Congo, the Congo is a rare
spot because it used to be grasslands,
but then it became a rain forest pretty
quickly and a lot of animals got trapped
that our grasslands,
animals like a antelopes and stuff,
they got trapped in the Congo and some
of them learn how to fucking swim.
There's a animal that's an antelope,
I think it's called a Diker
and it's swims and eats fish.
They can go under water a hundred
yards. I mean, it's fucking crazy.
This is an antelope man.
I mean it's adapted and evolved and if
you look at all of the animals that exist,
there's a BBC Congo documentary
that have a a brought up before.
If you could find it online, get
it. It's fucking sensational.
It just shows you all the
freaky shit that's in the Congo,
the birds and the lizards and the fucking,
the fish that come out of the water
and walk to the next part and jump in.
I mean that's fucking nuts man.
That's, it's, it's a really,
really weird spot in this world.
And what's this thing right
now it's just called Congo.
It's a BBC documentary on the Congo.
But these fucking things of this has
only happened over like a couple thousand
years.
And so they wonder like when did this
antelope starts swimming and eating fish?
Like before it was out a little like,
almost like a little tiny deer running
around, but now it's eating fish.
Like what the fuck man,
can you wonder? Like, you know,
they got that nuclear power plant down
the coast here and they talk about the
changes in the fish around there.
Cause there's a certain amount of heat
that emanates from the power plant into
the ocean. And they say that
there's been a change in, uh,
the looks of some of the fish.
Jesus Christ, a nice dinner.
I was wondering what, what
happens if you eat? I mean,
if I think it'd be really bad for the
fish to get all of that radio activity,
but how bad is it for you to
eat like a radioactive halibut?
Well, that's why they say don't eat
all fish. Don't eat fucking stuff. He,
he fished it lives and dies very quickly
because the longer they're around,
the more they're, they're taking
in, um, talk. What is it? Yeah,
but specifically what's the metal that
you are snakes. One of them? No. Um,
mercury. Mercury. Yeah. The
longer they live, the more
mercury goes in their system.
I had a, I tested for high levels of
arsenic from eating too many sardines.
No Shit. Yeah. I used
to like to eat sardines.
I see him like Canada and sometimes to
casting. How would you say? Disgusting.
But I enjoyed it. I smelled it.
I tried to make me feel bad.
Donald's breath went where
I did. Rosie O'donnell's a TV show. Ship
TV shot. Oprah's network firewall. Yeah.
Yeah. How was it? Sri? Nice.
Yeah. Yeah. She'd nice. Give
me a big hug and everything.
She's into conspiracy theories. She
just had a Hershey, oh yeah. Huge. Yeah.
She likes to talk nine 11. She likes
to talk. She's got some points.
He's got some valid points. Hey, I
respect that she didn't send up any,
a Wacko radar on my side. You
know, I'm all, I'm a one of
those guys that, uh, I'll,
I'll listen to anybody, anybody telling
any crazy conspiracy theory. I'll listen,
you know,
for the most part.
But I know when people are just like
really reaching and she wasn't, she's,
but she's,
you know,
she was on that show with like Elizabeth
handful back cause like they're really
hot. Chick is like Super Republican and
they would go to war about, you know,
like tower seven and
nine 11 conspiracies and
yeah. And she also said some
shit and she defend, uh, uh,
what's his name? Mel Gibson.
Mel. She really, she said,
I forget,
not a full on the fence,
but sort of like way more than
he should have gotten. Like,
but here's the thing about, I think
being somebody who is an alternate,
an alternate lifestyle person,
right,
is that you have to depart from the
status quo to be who you really are.
And I think with that,
you get some clarity and some truth in
your life that you can apply to other
things, conspiracy theories or
whatever. Cause she's, she's different.
So I think once you're labeled different,
frees you in a way
that's interesting. Yeah. Well,
she doesn't have to conform.
And she's a big lesbian. Everybody
knows who's a lesbian. She's powerful.
She's got a lot of money.
Chicks Schleicher she gets
hot chicks. It's kind of a,
it's a tricky situation.
He, Brian did we freeze up?
She shows him I'm frozen up. Okay. Just
came back when I asked you your video.
That's Voodoo. Yeah. We were frozen
for a lot of people. Watch the video.
I don't know that was many.
Um, we just, we, it's probably,
we would do way better if
we didn't even have it.
Do you? Sure. I just released
a podcast that was audio
only, Olive Garden podcasts.
It's called ready of garden butthole.
That's kind of olive garden,
but that's the name of the podcast and
we actually recorded live at the olive
garden. It's pretty
stupid. They let you do it.
We had a show the other day and these
people brought Brian breadsticks from the
Olive Garden Olive Garden
bag. It's becoming the most
ridiculous repetitive job.
It's so silly. But by the way, how awesome
was that fucking show? Oh, amazing.
Both Friday and Saturday night with Doug.
Stan hope and,
and Joey Diaz and Ari.
So much fun.
We uh,
we were supposed to do shows in Vegas and
I was supposed to have a UFC in Vegas,
but the flight got canceled so we
moved it to the Ice House that you,
do you go up there much besides a,
when you do my shows or do
you have to do weekends there?
I've never done it in my life. God loved
God. So one of the best clubs ever.
It's so perfect. It's just such
an old seasoned place short.
It's fucking like really low ceiling.
Like really tight, tight slide.
Perfect. Perfect. I did this.
I did some sort of a show.
I think George Lopez hosted it in 1994
those are the first time I ever went to
the ice house. Oh wait. It
was at any force on him?
What will you six TV for
for awhile. Damn, he was,
he was 20 and I was on stage at
the Ice House doing some TV show.
Yeah, I did the show. I think George
Lopez wasn't he the host of it?
Very Latino club too, isn't it?
Not Anymore. Now we white eat up.
Why did the shit out of it? Yeah,
it's still a lot of Latino's. Yeah.
That area has got a lot
of light to San Jose,
but we brought in a lot of white
boys, a lot of white kids. Just,
they said that there's a totally different
vibe to the club now since we've been
doing a lot of shows there,
which is great. You know, the,
the waiters and the people that work
there always complimenting the audiences
and stay on that. Yeah. We, we bring
in a nice group of people. We're,
we're super lucky and don't think that
we don't appreciate the fuck out of that
because I know people that are scared of
their audiences and they don't want to
hang out with their audience. They run
from them. You know, it's nice that uh,
you know, like after the show is when
we're always there talking. I mean we've,
we've had many nights where
we stay till one 30 then
no, I remember the lashline
he stood out there and they,
it was really nice and orderly. They
sorta like people lined up, they came in,
took a picture,
said hello.
Yeah, we just said, but there was a
lot of it is cool conversations too.
Like the guy who I told you, the
Iraq guy who told me, uh, you know,
about going over there and
flooding the economy with money.
He told me the whole really interesting
thing cause he was just a young kid or
would just fucking fucked up and joined
and areas and this crazy false pretest.
But he was talking about how he was
there and he was like, you know,
talking to someone who is like a sergeant.
Some guy had been there for
awhile and saying, well, you
know, we're over here to,
uh, you know, fight for freedom and
all that stuff. And the guy goes,
what the fuck are you talking about?
He goes, well, he had to get oil.
And he was like, what? Let's,
yeah, we're here for the oil.
We've got to control the oil. That's
why we're here. They built a Po,
a pipe from Kosovo. They already
prepared for this. And he was like, what?
And he remembers, you
know, talking about like,
he was talking to him about
how he remembers that.
That was just like a shattering moment
in his life. But he was like, Holy Shit,
this isn't a movie like
this, this, this is crazy.
He volunteered for some
nutty ass fucking war.
Well, every fucking war man,
every war that we've ever fought,
there's been another reason.
Yeah. But that one, you know, especially
the people that joined after nine 11,
there's a lot of people that join that
really thought they were going to do a
difference.
They really thought they were going to
go straight fucking war hero style and
reclaim America. Yeah, but don't
you think that's true? Every,
every war we've gotten it to pretty
much a, sorry, except Vietnam.
I think the reason why they had a drag
people in Vietnam was because Vietnam was
like super unpopular war that we would
probably never could get off today.
It just with the,
with the Internet,
you wouldn't be able to pull off
that sort of Gulf of Tonkin incident.
They would have to actually
have a real event. Really.
But they've done that before, man. You
know, Hitler did that. Nero did that.
Oh yeah.
The whole thinking of Alicia Tanea they
see something that happened 22 months
before we declared war.
That was it.
That was just an excuse we use
because we were in emerging nation.
We want it to be one of the big boys and
it was this war going on and we said,
fuck, if Germany wins,
we've been supplying,
we were making a ton of
money supplying the, uh,
the allied forces and if they lost,
we were never going to get day old as
fuck and billions in debt. They lost.
We weren't getting that money.
We went in there to hedge our bets and
make sure that it went the right way.
So we pretended the Lusitania was
the reason we were gone in a bunch of
Americans were on a
ferry ship that got sore.
Let's get in there and they played
it played on the heartstrings
well before drones and missiles and high
speed Aircrafts and all the shit that
we have today,
you had to use strategy
to win a war and strategy,
much like in chess involves sacrifice,
okay?
And there's no way to win a war if you're
not willing to sacrifice some of your
troops.
And unless you understand that you're
going to be a shitty general and you're
going to make even more people die,
okay?
So the realities of war dictate that you
do something unbelievably horrific and
make sure that a certain
amount of your people die.
Now, the final words said
by Marlon Brando, he says,
do you think we're going to win this war?
And he goes,
we came in and we vaccinated a
bunch of kids who, who would, uh,
who had been infected their arms or their
legs have been infected with gangrene
or whatever.
And we inoculated them and the tribal
elders came back and when they found out
we'd done it date machete
and off the limbs of all the
children. And that's when,
that's when Marlon Brando went.
He's like,
that's how you win a war when
you're willing to do that.
You win the war. Yeah. You gotta be
willing to take shit to the very,
very highest human level.
And that includes doing horrific
things to your enemy. I mean,
if you've read the accounts of what
the American soldiers did to American
Indians, native Americans, when
they were trying to clear out land,
they did some horrendous thing that
would wear like women's vaginas on their
hats. Condom out. Yeah. These
are American soldiers. Yeah.
There's a lot of accounts
to that kind of shit.
What is like hairpieces just
put it on their hat, you know,
like they have a fucking cowboy hat on.
Just stick a woman's pussy to their hat
that they cut off of an Indian that they
butchered out who are like native
American. I should say that.
The word fake mustaches. Well
I got, I got into this, uh,
this weird sort of uh, native, uh,
American fascination thing for a while
and I was reading like a lot of shit
about how, just the different
ways that the, the, the,
the people that migrated here,
it started just killing them.
Like how like these people had
no idea what the fuck was coming.
I mean it's a really,
an incredible amount of people were wiped
out over a short period of time and it
doesn't get nearly the amount of attention
and respect like in our culture does,
is it deserves,
yeah,
slavery gets a lot more cause it was
like just before we kind of like stopped
that sort of at the same time.
But you know,
it's really in a horrific thing when
you really stop and look at the actual
numbers of people that died.
People look at the Germans and they still
got, you know, the stigma of the Nazis.
In 10 minutes, we'll stay with the Germans
forever. But what you don't look at is,
you know,
what Great Britain did around the world,
whether you're talking about Africa,
Asia, India, you know what they,
the amount of people that died in the
name of manifest destiny or Christianity,
you know,
the British are truly the per capita
have committed more atrocities than any
race in history. And yet wasps in this
country, it doesn't get any better.
They are the most heralded.
There's no,
there's no racist jokes about the British
except her teeth. Yeah. That's it.
That's not bad.
Not Bad at all. It's truly
giant to a big vaginas. Yeah.
Cause they have bigger heads so that
their babies are, have bigger heads. Wow.
I didn't hear that park.
But yeah, it's, well,
what's really incredible is that we're
the byproduct of all that craziness.
All the raping and pillaging
and sword fighting and shit.
It's all come to,
you know,
native Americans being killed and
people tracking across it and boom,
here we are.
I mean we're at the very end of the time,
we're at the west coast of California,
the United States.
The last spot that people
settled in the free world.
This is the new world's final chapter.
I mean,
if you really stop and think about it,
there's no, unless Antarctica defrost,
we start moving
cities up there. But if that
becomes like the new cool place,
like the perfect weather to Greenland,
you know,
all of a sudden Greenland became,
no,
Iceland became the place because it
warmed the fuck up and they rent.
There's hot chicks and everybody went.
It became like the fastest growing
economy in the world for a while.
Call accept the fact that this whole
planet spins in a weird way and it goes
through cycles where shit gets really
fucking cold and when that happens in your
spot, you got to move. You can't be,
we can't be like completely
dedicated to one spot.
It's ridiculous because you look
at the history of the world,
they find these mega don teeth in Montana,
these giant shark teeth from his
fucking 80 foot long monster sharp.
They used to live, they find them in
Montana. That means Montana was the ocean.
Like you can't just say,
oh,
you can't goes away. It's going
to get you. You got it. You can't,
if you're living in Malibu, you're
living in a fucking dream. Okay.
Cause people that live like on
the water, good luck. Good call.
You're at the edge. Are you
that confidence that the
edge is going to stay there?
Do you put your finger
right near a fan every day?
That's what I done living in la
though. Oh yeah, you're right.
I mean in a certain extent,
but I think that if the real,
the real thing happens like that,
like something that the water comes
this far in, you know, we're dead.
We're already dead.
Well you look at down in Mexico at
Easter and we were in south of can't coon
that whole, that whole area. Yeah,
exactly. That shit was, you know,
we go into snow days and you go down a
hundred feet and they're showing you in
the caves. All of these fucking,
you know that the ocean,
basically,
there was a tsunami that landed on that
area and it took thousands of years for
the water to drain through that
land again. And it was just,
it was fucking underwater there.
They're finding hundreds of
cities in Europe and in the,
in the oceans. They're
finding the remanence is on a
constant basis. I'm like, uh,
uh, you know it's happening. I said
hundreds, but it's really been dozens,
but it really has been like super frequent
that they're finding more and more of
these ancient civilizations that are
underwater. It's just going to happen.
It's just what it is. The, the,
the earth doesn't give a fuck about you
remember that you used to be the whole
thing of like there's
the lost city of Atlanta.
It's like now there's
about a thousand of them.
There's places that went underwater.
There's so much underwater shit. There's,
I mean, and by the way, how
much shit is underwater.
I mean like what do you get like 10,000
years for the ocean changes it. Well,
you can never recognize it again.
How long does it actually stay with
all those waves and shit happening?
How long before that stuff
was unrecognizable roads,
sand and covered in sand and shit.
Fucking many sea ships are out there.
What a terrifying way to die.
That must've been getting a boat,
hit an iceberg and then realize you are
just fucking days by boat from anywhere
out in the middle of the I do it.
I
went,
I was boogie boarding yesterday and I
went too far out and big fucking waves.
So I get fucking slam first.
I'm going under these giant waves.
I mean these are like seven foot waves
and I start going under them and then,
which you normally can do, but then it
was fucking sucking me and I'd spin.
So I do it like three or four times and
I'm trying to go out past the waves so
that I can get my air
cause I ain't getting in.
I look out when I'm fucking like
50 yards out and I just start.
So then I finally catch one and take
it a little bit and then I go under,
flipped around and now
I can touch the sand.
But the waves are still fucking giant
and so they're landing on me and I can't
get under the wave.
So it's fucking hitting the into the
sand and spinning me and I can't get out.
So long story short,
I finally fucking just scramble
and there's a lifeguard
waist deep coming at me
and he's like, dude, you are right.
It's like you got fucking pounded.
And the thing is my wife, there's a
whole bunch of people watching my family,
all my friends and shit and they're
like, were you scared? And I was like,
I didn't have time.
It never occurred to me because
I'm sure it's like when you fight,
if you stop and are scared for a second,
you just lost your fucking
ability to problem solve.
And then my back is on fire today
and I realize how fucked up I got.
Well the only way to stop that
feeling is to get over it. No,
I mean that feeling being in water and
just getting tossed and like it's just
socks.
So if you haven't had an experience like
that where you have to really operate
under extreme pressure,
it can be really debilitating.
Some people just immediately give up.
It gets really scary where some people
find like surprising resolve and it's a
weird thing about human beings,
like how much your,
your mind is capable of doing
five minutes, but people
are one way or the other.
Yeah. Let's wrap this up because we're
running out of time at three hours.
USTREAM turns into a Pumpkin was
it three falls off every time.
Fitzsimmons I love it.
It's been a lot of fun buddy.
I mean as far as like people that have
known you like you're up there like one
of the longest people I'm still in
contact with in my life. Feels good. Yeah.
That's great buddy. We're gonna have some
fun. Play some pool. Definitely powerful.
But can I plug out,
when is it
Tarrytown, New York. September
14th at the Music Hall for,
let's do this as a promo code till uh,
till the ninth.
Go to Fitz dog.com get tickets putting
fits dog and the Promo Code when you get
your ticket's $10 tickets.
Tell your friends,
tell your family I got to jam this place.
Two shows on a Friday night.
I'll be doing the best material
I've been doing for three years.
Fucking nailed it down. I'm ready.
I want you there to share it with
you. Look very confident my friend. You
look ready to rock and roll. I feel right.
It was a very funny stand up. He's
been doing it like I said, 20.
What are we at 23 years now too.
It sounds about right.
So I'm like that crazy old school
skills son. So go check that out.
Where's your website again?
Fits dog.com Fatz and fits dog
radios the and go to death squad.
Get TV and get yourself a juicy, delicious
tee shirt out. This isn't a desk.
Why cut a desk? Go out and
get a TV. And I'm like,
what documents do you fuck
up the commercials that I
make for you? Silly Bitch.
Got a desk, squad.tv if you will, if
you'll ask where to get the um, the uh,
Brian Red Band versions of the desk, squad
tee shirts. They're all there. The, uh,
the one that I liked, the, I
liked the cat and the new one,
but I liked the thanks
for knocking my shirt.
I like your shirt, but I don't
like everything extended.
Like this one part of it.
I'm just telling you what I'm like.
Do you want me to lie?
I'm telling you what I like. You
tell me what you like. It's part of,
I've heard nothing but positive
things about everybody but me.
I love this free pussy riot
shirt that I got right here.
But the cool thing about the shirt is
that all of the proceeds go to desk
squad.tv.
So I can pay for everything.
And that's what the shirt is
about. Death Squad. Dot. TV.
Do you mean all the money goes to
you is what you're trying to say?
So you can get to get paid for this
thing pays for everything in this thing.
I pay. Oh, nevermind. I don't
want you to do. Okay. So yeah,
the t shirt goes right to all the podcasts
that I provided@desksquad.tv and all
the shows you heard that
ladies and gentlemen. Uh,
thanks to [inaudible] dot com that's
o, n n, I, t, a maker's of Alpha brain,
new mood shroom tech, and the new
hemp force with Makkah and raw cocoa.
Go get some of that.
And um,
we will see you guys tomorrow with the
Great Ari Shaffir and we will see you
guys Thursday with the Great Rick Ross,
the real Rick Ross. Not that rapper dude,
but the actual guy that gets up,
she'll be cool. Thank you guys.
We'll see you soon.
Okay.
Yeah.